four
three two one boom and we're live
12 rules for life so without reading
this
so what you're saying is
there's only 12 things you need to know
in life right that's it yeah well
yeah this um this interview that you
just did
with this woman uh kathy newman was that
in the uk it was channel 4
uk um i just went i i felt bad but i was
also laughing i went to her twitter page
to read like and in with each one of her
tweets no matter what she says
someone writes underneath it so what
you're saying is and then some ridicul
but
by the way the your fans
were mocking her but politely
non-aggressively there were i didn't
read any rude
things like there was no there was there
was no insults or
there were well maybe a few insults but
there's no swears it was
just playful mocking of the interview
that she did with you because
the interview was ridiculous it was a
ridiculous interview and i listened to
it
or watched it several times i was like
this is so strange
like her determination to turn it into a
conflict
to it's one of the issues that i have
with television shows
yeah because they have a very limited
amount of time and they're trying to
make things as salacious as possible
they want to have these
sound bites these click bait sound bites
and she just went into it incredibly
confrontational not trying to find your
actual perspective
but trying to force you to defend a non
non-realistic perspective yes well i was
the i was the hypothetical villain of
her imagination essentially
well what happened what was interesting
too the way it it
played itself out because i met her in
the green room beforehand you know she
was being made up and then they put a
little bit of powder on me and
we had a friendly kind of interchange
and then we went and sat in front of the
cameras and for a couple of minutes
you know before before the show got
rolling and we had a pretty pleasant
back and forth and then as soon as the
cameras went on she was a completely
different person
and i thought oh i see
what's going on yeah yeah well so so
that kind of alerted
me to well the fact that there was
something rotten in the state of denmark
let's say
yeah but you know this is also why
youtube is going to kill tv
because television by its nature all of
these narrow broadcast
technologies they re they rely on
forcing the story
right because it has to happen now it
has to happen in like often in five
minutes because
they only broadcast five minutes of that
interview
they did put the whole thing up on
youtube to their credit
it it it hasn't ceased to amaze me yet
i think that they thought that the
interview went fine
that's the scuttlebutt i've got from
sort of behind the scenes because i've
you know i know some people who know
what's going on at channel four and
they're shell-shocked by the response
you know and and then of course there is
the counter response the guardian the
next day
published a paper or published an
article saying that
you know the head of channel 4 had to
call in police security because of
threats
you know well first of all you can call
the police in about anything
and they never did detail out exactly
what the threats were
you know but then about 20 newspapers
picked that up and went for the
well kathy newman is now being harassed
by an army of online trolls for doing
nothing but doing her job
which well i and then there was a
backlash against that in the press
and so it's been a well
well someone took an audit of the the
actual
interchanges that yep between fans and
her and there was way more negative ones
coming your way
yes that were seriously negative yeah
that's right seriously negative
violent harassing just rude
there were way more yeah and no one
picked up on that at all it was all
the narrative was she's a victim even
though
she was highly aggressive on in this but
she's a funny victim it's not like she's
not successful yeah you know it's like
at some point you think you should have
to hand in your victim card
i think like when you go to an ivy
league university it's like right then
and there you go
yeah because you don't get to be
oppressor and oppressed at the same time
that's just too much well one of the
things that you pointed out was when you
were talking about
competition for very lucrative jobs and
you were saying
look what you've done like you you must
have had to work here
and she proudly was saying how how hard
she had to work
yeah to get there i'm like well yes of
course no one's going to hand this to
you
no this is why and this is why you were
saying you are opposed to
equality of outcome i can't imagine
anything we could possibly strive for in
our society that would make it into hell
faster than equality of outcome like the
historical
the historical evidence for the
pathology of that root is so strong
it's like you have to be
historically ignorant beyond belief or
malevolent or
resentful beyond comprehension in order
to think that that's a good idea
i argue for that i agree with you but i
think that even if you came into this
with no knowledge of history but a
complete understanding of human beings
you would say well that doesn't make any
sense and one of the best quotes that
i've ever read about it is that if you
have real true freedom
you're never going to have equality of
outcome because with real true freedom
you have the freedom to not engage
well look if you look at a guy like jeff
bezos for instance that amazon guy is
worth more money than anybody ever
right that guy works all day yeah i mean
he's a maniac oh he's
acquiring all these different companies
and and everything he's doing
is designed to succeed i mean he's just
well that's what gates just said
too in a recent interview and i know
some guys that are you know they're
in approximately the same universe as
those two and
they just work all the time that's all
the time and they don't just work they
work so
efficiently and so effectively and make
use of every second in ways you can't
even imagine unless you're in that sort
of position
so and you know doing that doesn't mean
that you will succeed but
not doing it certainly means that you
will fail well you s
well not doing it certainly means you
will never achieve that level of success
and that's what we're talking about
we're talking about a quality of outcome
i don't want that i don't want to be
that guy i don't want to work like that
i don't want to do what he's doing and i
should have the freedom to not do that
yeah as he should have the freedom to do
that if we're going to play this game
called capitalism which we're all
agreeing is probably at least in
as far as the models that we have right
now is the best one that we have if
we're all going to play this game
if someone decides to be the michael
jordan of capitalism you can't stop them
you can't say no no no you're playing
this game too well you're playing this
team too hard you're too obsessed with
this game
you're going to have that yeah you can
stop them you can try to stop people
from winning crookedly
which is what you should do and yes you
know there's a couple of things that are
really worth delving into with regards
to that too because
there's this sort of marxist notion that
all this inequality is generated as a
consequence
of capitalism and that's actually
technically false
because if you look at there's a there
seems to be something like a law of
nature that's
described by this statistical model
called the pareto distribution
and it basically suggests that in any
creative domain
there's going to be a small number of
people will will do almost all of the
output but it doesn't just apply to
human beings
it implies it applies to the heights of
trees in the amazon rainforest
it applies to the size of cities and it
applies to the mass of stars
which is something like the more you
have the more you get
it's something you can imagine how that
would work with a star as it gets bigger
and bigger and its gravitational mass
increases
it's going to attract more and more
matter and then as the city grows well
more and more people are excited to move
there because of all the opportunities
and so
some cities start to grow tremendously
and others and others don't
but this this this
uh phenomena where a small number of
people end up controlling a tremendous
proportion of the resource
is not only limited to money and it
doesn't only occur in capitalist
societies
it occurs everywhere it's like a natural
law so you see the same thing with
number of
points scored by a you know a
spectacular sports figure
there's always a tiny proportion of
people who are way way
the head way ahead on the curve or
people who make records or people who
sell paintings or people who compose
music
or people who sell music online it's all
the same it's
it's the one percent gets 80 percent and
so
well first we can't blame that on
capitalism and second we should note
that it actually does constitute a
problem which is what the left-wingers
are always jumping up and down about
right like too much inequality
starts to destabilize your society and
it isn't obvious how to shovel
money from the top end maybe the one
tenth of one percent who have almost all
the money
down to the people who have almost
nothing in a way that's effective
so that they don't get thrown out of the
game completely and so that the whole
society doesn't
destabilize we don't exactly know how to
do that it is a problem because
inequality does exist and it does tend
to magnify across time
and then there's another problem too
which we haven't figured out is
imagine that in order to make everyone
rich
you have to tolerate a certain amount of
inequality that seems obvious
we don't know how many units of
inequality you need to tolerate per unit
of wealth generated
but the answer is definitely not zero
it's definitely not zero
so yeah so it goes back to this equality
of outcome yeah
yeah and this this thing has
perplexed me since i've met you and
since
uh you were involved in this original
debate over gender pronouns
and there was an article that was
written recently i forget the exact
title of it
i think it was something along the lines
of why can't people hear what jordan
peterson is saying
yeah you are misrepresented more than
anyone i know
in a weird way you are villainized in a
weird way
where um i can't believe that these
people are honestly
looking at your opinions and coming up
with these conclusions
i i can't help but feel like what is
happening
is people are consciously deciding
to ignore reality and paint you as this
archetypal figure of oppressive white
male
patriarchy ignorance
fill in the blank with all the the rest
of the descriptives that you'd like to
use but
they've decided to paint you in this way
like
as as a target because
they need a target to sort of reinforce
this idea
that transgender people are being
victimized and women are being
victimized and
well even deeper that the right
narrative is the way that we should view
the world is
victim versus oppressor because that's
the basic post-modern neo-marxist
template it's the right way to view the
world is that
it's a power it's a power ground it's a
what it's a
it's a battleground of power interests
competing constantly
the ones that win are oppressors the
ones that lose are oppressed that's the
way you look at the world
and i think that that's wrong that's a
bad way of looking at the world
psychologically sociologically
politically economically ideologically
you name it now it ends in nothing but
catastrophe
i mean first of all because it puts your
group identity as something that's
paramount
and i mean that's just not well that for
that isn't what we do in the west
let's say we put your individual
identity paramount
and then well that's just that's just
for starters fundamentally and then i
guess the other reason that people are
on my case to some degree is because i
have made a strong case
which i think is fully documented by the
scientific literature that there are
intrinsic differences say between men
and women and i think the evidence in
that
this is the thing that staggered me is
that no
serious scientists have debated that for
like four decades
it's that argument was done by the time
i went to graduate school everyone knew
that
human beings were not a blank slate that
biological forces
not parameterized the way that we
thought and and felt and acted and
and and valued everyone knew that the
fact that this has become somehow
debatable again is just
especially because it's being done by
legislative fiat they're forcing it
to me as a scientist it's just it's just
well and in the states too
with tight with title ix for example
because title ix is sort of predicated
on that viewpoint
what is title now oh title ix was
originally just a piece of legislation
that
um mandated that female sports teams
were funded to the same degree that male
sports teams were funded
in american universities but it's been
expanded out so that if there's any
differences
in any areas whatsoever between the
genders then the universities are being
taken to court
and like 200 i mean last i looked about
200 of them were up
and and they can have their funding
revoked if they violate the title ix
provisions
so it's become like a vicious weapon for
social justice warrior
equality of outcome types so it's not
just about
sports no it's got way way beyond that
yeah it's it's it's become an equality
of outcome
issue fundamentally there was an article
that i sent you
um one of them was uh from i think uh
like i thought i got it off of digg.com
but it was um
jordan peterson is having his moment and
we should ignore him and i send this to
you and there was one
probably the last part of that might be
true
[Laughter]
but one of the things in the article was
citing this study that showed very
little difference
oh god it's a pathetic study yeah well i
said it to you because i was like this
this is not right well the thing is like
most things
it's complicated yes you know so are men
and women more
similar or more different well it
depends on how you define the terms
first but they're more similar well why
well they're the same species
so we could start with that like but
the question is what are the differences
and how do they manifest themselves and
are those manifestations important so
here's an example if you took
a random woman out of the population and
a random man and you had to bet on who
was more temperamentally aggressive
if you bet on the man you'd be right 60
percent of the time
but you'd be wrong 40 of the time and
that that's not a walloping difference
right 60 40. it's not 90
10 like so there's quite there's a lot
of overlap between men and women in
terms of their levels of aggression
and you think well they're more the same
yeah
except so then let's say no no let's
play a slightly different game
let's pick the in a hundred most
aggressive person
from the random population well they're
all men
and that's why all the people in prison
are men so even though
on average men and women most well yeah
it's 90
90 90 to 95 right so and often if the
women are in prison it's because they
got tangled up with a really bad guy
you know so so one of the problems is is
that
differences at the extreme are where the
differences really start to manifest
themselves
and so you can have a small difference
at the level of the average
but out at the extremes it starts to
make a massive difference
so let's say to be a google engineer
which is hard right
because you not only have to be an
engineer but you have to be a very good
engineer
say well you have to be interested in
things rather than people
that's that's a huge difference in
interest like men are more interested in
things generally speaking and women are
more interested in people generally
speaking now there's still a lot of
overlap between them but
that's one of the biggest differences
between men and women it's been
demonstrated cross-culturally it's also
a very big difference in the
scandinavian countries
well on average the difference isn't
that great
even though it's a relatively large
difference but at the extremes it's the
same thing
almost all the people are hyper um
what would you call hyper focused on
things they're almost all men
and all the people who are hyper focused
on people are almost all women and so
how does that play out in the world well
in the scandinavian countries it plays
out this way
about 85 percent of nurses in
scandinavia are female
and about 85 to 90 percent of engineers
are male
it doesn't mean women can't be engineers
it doesn't mean men can't be nurses
it also doesn't have anything to do with
intelligence
but it does have to do with interest and
the differences in interest are big
now at the extremes in particular so
when you read a review like that the one
that was pointed out the first question
is well
what do you mean by big and little
there's more overlap
there's more overlap between men and
women than there is difference on
virtually every parameter
okay fine are the remaining differences
significant in how they play out in the
world
the answer to that is overwhelmingly
significant because you
you select for extremes so here's
another example
ashkenazi jews have an average iq of 115
so in the typical population overall has
an average iq of 100.
15 points is about the difference
between the typical college student and
the typical high school student
okay so it's not a massive difference
but if you go
to the extreme say well let's go look at
people who only have an iq of 145
which is kind of where you hit the
beginnings of genius level it's like the
jews are overwhelmingly over represented
so relatively small differences
in the average can produce walloping
differences at the extremes
people don't understand that it's not
surprising because it actually requires
a fairly sophisticated grasp of
statistics but when we're talking about
things like
differential outcome in the workplace
then you have to take a sophisticated
statistical approach to it or you don't
know what the hell you're talking about
and
unfortunately many of the people who are
talking about things like gender
differences
they have no idea what they're talking
about they don't know the literature
they don't know there is a literature
they don't understand biology like the
the social constructionist types the
women's studies types the neo-marxist
they don't give a damn about biology
it's like they
inhabit some disembodied universe so
the review was poorly written at best
and
did not was showed a very
poor grasp of the relationship between
group differences
and economic and practical outcomes it's
not just that it's deceptive
and there's there's a need in some way
on that side this side of the debate the
anti-jordan peterson side to
label men and women as being virtually
identical
when there's so much evidence that
that's not the case
and what you're saying what you've
you've never said
one is superior one is inferior what you
are
is a guy who's pointing out the reality
of the difference between
the various types of human beings and
you've been very open about
the extremes about you look i'm i'm well
aware of the extremes i deal with
mma fighters i know a lot of female mma
fighters are
as aggressive and as tough as any man
you're ever going to meet in your life
and i know a lot of men from comedy that
are meek little guys who
they're not nearly as aggressive as some
of these female fighters like
there's i think one of the beautiful
things about freedom
is that people get an opportunity to
express themselves
in a way that's genuinely them yep and
whether that is like
uh our friend alex honold who's a a free
climber
who is like climbing up these fantastic
mountains with no ropes
or whether it's a female mma fighter
like raquel pennington who's
just a tank and beating the [ __ ] out of
people and that's what she loves to do
all of these extremes are available to
people because of freedom
this is not a suppressive thing no one's
anyone's stopping people from choosing
these paths
i don't know if you saw the most recent
slip up by
the ceo of youtube i retweeted it today
um they were talking about why there's
not as many women in tech
and she basically said they both her and
the ceo of google
said exactly what james damore was
saying in his memo
they completely [ __ ] up they tried to
look
did you find this look at this this is
goddamn hilarious and james damore had
this on his page
they respond women a lack of tackles
could you now go to joe go to james
damore's tweet
just go to the the what i retweeted and
what he said
so there was a study published a while
ago about j
no jamie scroll back right it's right
there it's right there just just make
his tweet larger there you go
look see it said he's saying did i read
this right i don't know how to say her
name is susan what
i'm sorry i don't know how to say her
name w-o-j-i-c-i-c-k-i
said that women find geeky male
industries
as opposed to social industries not very
interesting
and sundar cites research on gender well
that's
that's exactly the difference in
interest that i just pointed out yeah
this is right he
this is what james damore wrote in his
memo that got him fired
and this in my mind if i was the lawyer
for james damore i'd be like oh
well look who we have here this is this
is checkmate yeah you dummies
you just said the divorce story is
really interesting you know because
i think it's such a classic story of of
an engineer getting tangled up in
politics so
damore went to this diversity seminar
and he wasn't very happy about it
because he knew the literature
and so at the end of the seminar they
asked for feedback
well james damore is an engineer so when
you tell an engineer
that you want feedback the engineer
thinks oh you want feedback and
you and you want like facts and stuff
right because that's what feedback would
be like
so damore went and wrote this like
thorough memo and gave it to them he
said well you know
this is what i think here's some
feedback and then
it traveled around he got no real
response from the diversity people and
then he posted it on
one of these internal boards at google
where people can discuss things
which people at google do all the time
so it was perfectly reasonable for him
to post it because he didn't get a
response from the diversity people he
thought well let's see what other people
think
and then it was there for a long time
until it was leaked up
into the outside world it wasn't like
damore was trying to expose
google for for what it is he was just
doing what an engineer type would do
when someone asked him to provide
feedback because he's not thinking
politically he's not thinking oh they
just want to hear what they already said
he thought they actually wanted some
facts anyways i think they picked on the
wrong guy
because it turns out to be pretty damn
tough well he's very smart and a very
kind guy
when you sit down and talk to him he's
not a sexist he's a
he's a guy that's talking about facts in
fact he wrote
more than a page and a half i believe on
strategies for getting more women
interested in tech he's not a sexist
this is just a guy that was talking
about the differences and the choices
that people make that's based on
just the the variations that you were
just discussing well there's a good
study done a while ago and unfortunately
i don't remember the author but they
were looking
at junior high math prodigies and
they're they're pretty equally
distributed between boys and girls
but by the time university came along
the math prodigy boys they tend to go
into the stem fields but the girls
wouldn't
and it isn't because they lacked ability
because they had stellar ability
it's because they weren't interested and
it turns out like the interest thing
turns out to be a big one so
with personality alone if you measure
men and women's personalities and then
you add up all the differences in
personalities
you could tell with about 75 to 80
certainty
by looking at a full personality readout
whether a person is male
or female so you'd be wrong 25 percent
of the time something like that
but if you add interest to that you can
get up to about 90 percent
and so you know you say well are these
differences large
well individually they're not that big
they make more difference at the
extremes but if you add them up
then you can almost completely
differentiate men from women
so by that token they're they're very
large and the interesting actually turns
out to matter a lot like it's probably
the most important individual difference
that has been discovered between men and
women at the psychological level
it has real decent explanatory power
because you might say
well men have a slight edge in spatial
intelligence and that's why they're over
represented in stem
fields and women have a slight edge in
verbal intelligence this is debatable
but
literature kind of indicates that and
that's why they're overwhelmingly
the majority of fiction readers for
example
is that the reason that there's
differential representation in the stem
fields it's like no it doesn't seem to
be it doesn't look like it's an
intellectual issue
which is also what de moore pointed out
by the way he never said once that
this was a cognitive issue but it's a
matter of choice
matter of interest and women tend to be
more
more people-oriented now the thing is
this is also being discovered in
chimpanzees and other primates
like if you offer baby or or
child chimpanzees juvenile chimpanzees
the toys
choice between thing like toys like cars
or people like toys like dolls the males
will go for the thing like toys and the
females will go for the people-like toys
so you see that in primates
and you think well is that surprising
it's like well no it's not it's not that
surprising
really i mean women have to take care of
infants
tiny infants and you have to be really
people oriented to do that because
a tiny infant is an unbelievably
demanding
social relationship and it's a primary
relationship for about two years
you know and so women are tilted towards
the kind of temperament
that makes that possible it's like well
is that such a shock
really that's such a surprise so
no it's not a surprise and what what's
confusing to me is the narrative
that anybody that points out these
differences
is somehow a sexist or discriminatory
or yeah worse yeah yeah well whatever
epithet they can well i think the other
reason that the way
the left the radical lefties have been
going after me constantly is
well there's one reason is is if you
stand up against the radical radical
left
you're in a group that also has nazis in
it because the nazis also stand up
against the radical left
so it's perfectly reasonable from a
strategic perspective for the radical
leftists to say well
you're against us how do we know you're
not a nazi it's like well statistically
statistically i'm probably not you know
so there's that but
but you could say at least the question
is open but but
but then the next part of it comes is
that it's motivated
epithet slinging because if i'm
reasonable
and i'm standing up against the radical
left and they admit that i'm reasonable
then there has to be an admission that
reasonable people could
stand up against the radical left which
kind of implies that the radical left
isn't that reasonable
and so while they're not going to go
there of course they're not that
reasonable they're
unreasonable beyond belief as we saw in
this situation with lindsay shepard in
canada
so at wilford laurier university let's
talk about that real quick because
that was a fascinating thing too and
that also had to do with you
so she was discussing you in class
and you could fill up everybody yeah
she's in the communications
in the communications department at
wilford laurier and
they were talking about uh the
the role of language in communication
which kind of what you would do in a
communication class
and she decided to show a five-minute
clip from a program i had done
for tv ontario which is a public
television station mainstream
left-leaning liberal television station
news program and a good one a good one
and i had been on there with a number of
other people including a professor
nicholas matt from the university of
toronto who claimed essentially that
there were no biological differences
between men and women and that had been
the scientific consensus for the last
four decades
so anyway she showed a clip from this
and
well she got hauled in front of two
professors
and an administrator adria joel who was
basically hired for that purpose and
raked over the coals for daring to show
this video and
she had that wherewithal to tape it
and then she made the tape public and in
that tape they compared me it was it was
really
blackly comical you know they compared
me to hitler
yeah and but then said well it's hitler
or milo yiannopoulos i thought you guys
you're so damn clueless you can't even
get your insults right it's like
you can't say that's like playing a
video of hitler
or milo yiannopoulos it's like first of
all hitler and milo yiannopoulos
they're actually not in the same
category right except that they're both
human
that's about the narrowness of the
category
and and then milo's uh like a comic
provocateur
and you can hate him or love him or or
be indifferent
but to put him in the same category as
hitler just shows how muddle-headed you
are and then to assimilate me to that
category so carelessly
like you don't mess about with epithets
like that
you know hitler was one of the great
super villains of the 20th century right
i mean he was he's up there with stalin
and mao in the in a in the panoply of
satanically possessed leaders
you don't just toss that around
especially not when you're
torturing your teaching assistant for
daring
to show a video about language in a
communication class
and so that was a massive scandal in
canada it was the biggest
sk i think it was the biggest scandal
that ever hit a university in canada and
it got a lot of international attention
and rightly so and she also turns out to
be a tough cookie
i mean the last i heard she was she'd
started a club at
wilford laurier and i think it was last
night or the night before maybe it's
coming up
they're going to show the whole video
from television ontario
at a club meeting and invite people to
come and discuss it it's like
they they picked on the wrong girl there
too so they certainly did she was
obviously
very smart you could hear that in her
discussion with them and how
flabbergasted she was by their take on
things
but this was essentially proof to a lot
of people that were on the outside of
how preposterous
some of the dialogue was inside these
universities yeah well they couldn't
have done me a bigger favor
than having that scandal because when i
made the videos about bill c-16
15 months ago i said look here's what's
going to happen because this
legislation is written in an appalling
manner and the surrounding policies are
pathological
so here's what's going to happen and and
so i laid it out and then people came
out and said
no you're being paranoid it's like
that's possible no the bill the
legislation isn't going to have that
effect
no you're not a legal expert what the
hell do you know et cetera et cetera
you're crazy you're a bigot you're a
trans full
you know they threw everything but the
kitchen sink at me
and like fair enough you know because
there's always a possibility that i was
wrong
but the problem was is i read the
policies and i understood them and i
knew where they were leading
but i never imagined that one of the
consequences of bill c-16 in its sister
legislation was that
a teaching assistant at a canadian
university would be pilloried and
accused of breaking the law
and then accused of all sorts of
reprehensible political beliefs
by two professors and an administrator
hired for that purpose
merely because she showed a video about
two people
talking about the law it's like that
that
paranoid as i am let's say that
that exceeded the grasp of the reach of
my imagination
and then of course it was made public
and people just couldn't believe it and
then
you think okay well what's the defense
well they misinterpreted bill c-16
it's like no i don't think so um
they aren't representative of the
university professor
administration well all of pimlot and
rambukana's colleagues
rose to their defense the whole
department the university when they
apologized did it in a very
mealy-mouthed way
like there's no evidence that it was an
anomalous occurrence
so what had happened is they
overextended the reach of bill c-16 in
exactly the way that i said would happen
it was inevitable
and it wasn't an anomaly it was actually
that's
actually the way that the universities
are and it is the way that they are
it wasn't a one-off it was exactly
diagnostic
and it's appalling it's appalling the
universities have so much to be ashamed
of
they're they're well there was an
article in the boston globe this week
saying the same thing that
all of this crazy post-modern identity
politics equality of outcome nonsense
is not only disrupted the university in
a way that might be
irreparable as far as i can tell but
it's rapidly spreading outside into the
normal say business world which was
exactly what you see for example at
google
well the tech industry in particular
seems to be
like more left-leaning than pretty much
any industry there is
and i guess it's because there's so many
intelligent people there so many people
that
have spent a tremendous amount of time
in universities and they get
indoctrinated into this mindset
and you're you're seeing that in this
the the ceo of youtube's response to
james damore memo completely
misrepresented
it they're talking about harmful gender
stereotypes that's not what he talked
about at all
um what what's fascinating to me about
all of this
is it it just reeks of tribalism
that these people on the left have
decided
i mean and i'm mostly on the left which
is really crazy
i mean when it comes to most policies
and most thoughts of equality
and and the idea of just letting people
be who they are i mean that's what the
left used to stand for
it used to stand for being open-minded
it used to stand for
being a reasonable person it now it
seems to
be all about this very toxic tribal
ideology and
this is one of the reasons why so many
of these attacks and you are so
baffling to me is because there's a
willful ignorance
or a deceptive narrative there there's a
deceptive description of who you are and
what you're saying and what you
represent
and it's this conveniently categorized
not even convenient willfully
willfully deceptively categorized into
these category
categories of homophobia transphobia
sexism these are
reprehensible categories that if they
can just shove
something that you're saying figure out
a way to push you into this little
narrow confined then everyone has to
disagree with you
everyone has to insult you and everyone
has to
like take that girl into their office
and
chastise you for even using not even
speaking up
for you right just she said she wasn't
yes that's what was more fascinating
about it than anything
yeah then they give her hell for that
like all you can't present something
like that neutrally
that's like presenting something hitler
said neutrally or maybe milo
yiannopoulos
it's it's so strange but what they don't
understand and this is what's really
crazy is that the world
is watching and that most people
but maybe it's a 60 40 like we were
talking about before when it comes to
aggressive men
women versus aggressive men i don't know
what the number
is i think it's about 50 to one actually
like i've been watching the comments on
youtube and so forth trying to track
this it's like i think that
like i think that what the radical
leftists are doing is
overwhelmingly um unrepresentative of
the general population
overwhelmingly but they're they're a
very
well organized and and verbal
and prepared minority and they've
occupied
powerful positions in many many
institutions hr
one of the things i really can't figure
out right now and for anybody who's
running a company that's listening they
should think this through
like to let these postmodern
neo-marxists into your company through
the guise of human resources is an
absolute catastrophe you're going to pay
for that
this the ideology that drives
post-modern neo-marxism this identity
politics
uh what the identity politics movement
and its insistence on equality of
outcome is a powerfully
anti-capitalistic
it's powerfully anti-western why you
would let that into your company
is so that you can look good socially
let's say is beyond me it's a big
mistake
i agree with you but i don't think
people are aware of it i think part of
the problem is this
battleground is largely ignored by the
general population i don't think most
people are aware of what's going on
you are because you're obviously you're
deeply embedded in the university system
in canada and you're you're obviously
now uh branching out into youtube and
podcasts and all these different ways to
get this information out but
the average person that is a ceo of a
company or they're they're concerned
with their own company they're concerned
with their own
individual needs they're concerned with
organizing things and keeping their
bottom line and
yeah well they're also concerned with
looking fair and making sure that
they're not prejudiced and all of that
which is laudable and
but i just don't think they see the wave
coming no they don't they don't see it
coming they don't understand it
and they're in cautious about it but
they're going to pay for it well google
is a good example because now google is
in court
on the feminist end for like being
prejudiced against females and also on
the conservative end for being
prejudiced against
conservatives it's like well so both
camps are after them and i think well
why is that it's like well that's what
happens when you play identity politics
this tribalism
now this is really what i can't stand
about identity politics and i've been
warning about the consequences of
on the right wing too because what i see
happening is that
as the left like let's say the left gets
to define the linguistic territory which
is what i was objecting to in bill c-16
when it came out i said look
i'm not going to use these neologisms z
and zur etc
because as far as i'm concerned they
have nothing people who don't know what
you're
talking about yeah a bunch of different
made up gender
pronouns yeah to describe people in the
non-male or female
that's right so there's like 70
different categories of non-binary
gender
something like that generated now and
there's lists of pronouns that
hypothetically the people who are in
those categories can
choose to be addressed by and now that
has the force of law
and so and i don't care if they choose
to be addressed by those pronouns
whatever that's that's that's that's up
to them
and whoever else they can convince or
ask or entreat or negotiate with fine
as soon as it's law that's a whole
different story okay so now i have to
use a certain terminology
so then i look at the derivation of the
terminology i say oh
that's terminology generated by the
postmodern neo-marxists oh well
i think those people are reprehensibly
murderous so guess what
i'm not going to say their words period
because i know what they're like i know
where that leads
okay so but most people think that
that's a
gigantic step to go from saying you
don't want to say
z or zero or any of these made up gender
pronouns to
these are murderous people the ideology
is murderous
the ideology being marxism yeah
absolutely well jesus how much proof of
that do you need
most people don't understand marxism
like when you when you're saying this
like
when you were so adamant about it i had
to start reading about it myself
and i had to start doing a lot of
research about it myself and
i think most people hear marxism and
they think socialism yep
they think uh pooling all your money
together you know making
you know making things more even for
people yeah like they are in venezuela
everybody has an equal chance to starve
to death so you know how they you know
how the venezuelan government start
solved the problem of kids starving to
death in hospitals
how they made it illegal for the doctors
to report starvation as the cause of
death
right wow that's venezuela in a nutshell
yeah that's everyone's equal there
they all have the same number of bones
to gnaw on
yeah that's a horrible thing but yeah
it's it's a horrible thing
undeniably but there's no like the
connection between
gender pronouns and murder
this it's a big leap yeah that's that's
for sure that's for sure well that's why
you have to look at the underlying
ideology you know and you think well
what's what level at
what is the level at which these things
should be addressed well is it economic
is it political
is it personal meanings of these this
ideology and you understand
where the road map leads you understand
the x at the end of the road
yeah right absolutely well and i think
that's why i recommend it to people
continually to read soldier knits in
school like archipelago
so actually there's a set of books that
let lay this out perfectly you read
dostoevsky's wrote a book called the
possessed or the devils
and it's a it's a description of the
initial breakdown of the
of orthodox christian society in in
russia in the late 1800s
and the rise of radical socialist ideas
so it's sort of like the pro drama to
the russian revolution it's a brilliant
brilliant book
brilliant book and it concentrates on
the personalities that are involved
and then if you read after that
solzhenitsyn's gulag archipelago where
he details what he
does in that book is quite remarkable so
he says look there were tens of millions
of people killed
from 1919 to 1959 in the soviet union
and as a consequence of internal
repression and it's so
dreadful that words can't do it justice
i mean it's absolutely dreadful what
happened in the soviet union
i mean just for starters 6 million
ukrainians died in the 1930s because of
enforced starvation in fact in in in the
1930s here's here's how here's how
terrible it was
so all the food that the collective
farmers newly collectivized farmers
had produced which wasn't very much by
the way was taken from them and brought
to the cities
so all the farmers starved to death now
here's here's how draconian it got
so let's say you were the mother of some
children and
all your grain had been shipped off to
the cities and you thought well i'm not
going to have my children starved to
death
i'm going to go out in the field and i'm
going to on my hands and knees
and i'm going to pick up the grains that
are left over that the harvesters didn't
count get and i'm going to feed those to
my kids that was punishable by death
you were supposed to hand in those extra
bits of grain so that they could be
shipped to the city as well
so that was just the beginning of the
fun in the soviet union and what
solzhenitsyn did was say look
this wasn't a consequence of the marxist
system gone wrong this was a consequence
of the marxist
system it was inevitable consequence of
the
axioms of the marxist system and then he
lays that out and
and it's well i think he got it right
and what is that
won the nobel prize but what is the
connection
how much tyranny you have to impose in
order to produce something like equality
of outcome
the the and thomas sowells talked about
this a little bit too he said
what the people who are agitating for
equality of outcome don't understand
is that you have to cede so much power
to the authorities to the government
in order to ensure equality of outcome
that a tyranny is inevitable
and that's right and the other pro
another problem with equality of outcome
this is also a big technical problem is
like well
what measure of outcome you know there's
lots of outcomes like
how happy are you how much pain are you
in how healthy are you
how much money do you have how much
opportunity for movement forward
do you have what's the width of your
social connections
like what's the quality of your
friendships do you have exposure to art
and literature like you know you can
multiply the number of dimensions of
evaluation between people
innumerably right because there's
there's all sorts of ways to classify
people
you're going to get equality of outcome
on every one of those measures
is like everyone going to have to be
equally happy in their relationship
and if not why not why why stop with
economic
why stop with pay there's no place to
stop
so and that's that's a huge technical
problem because there is no place to
stop there will be no stopping
it's like nobody can have anything else
nobody can have anything that everyone
else doesn't have at the same time
that's the ultimate outcome of equality
of outcome well you think about what
that would mean
it's terrible well instantly you think
oh well there's nothing but a tyrannical
system could impose that
have you ever debated a marxist
supporter have you ever debated someone
who
is pro-equality of outcome no they don't
debate me
well the only the closest thing i think
was to that was the debate i did at the
university of toronto about the bill
c-16 issues
but they didn't actually have a debate
they had a forum which is the
post-modern equivalent of a debate it's
supposed to be friendlier i suppose
um but no i haven't because people don't
do it they don't
ask me to do it but what is it about
that
idea or that ideology about marxism
that's so
attractive to young students
and to university people well that's a
good question i think it goes back to
the issue of inequality and and
this is something that has to be dead
seriously addressed like you might say
well why is the left wing necessary
let's let's put it that way
so and then a subset of that would be
well why is the left wing attractive
well the left wing is necessary because
inequality does spiral out of control
and so there has to be a political voice
for the dispossessed
and you you don't want people to stack
up at zero
you know where they can't play the game
at all it's a bad idea not only
do you not if people stack up at zero
they're too poor to get ahead at all
let's say
they're too poor to open a bank account
they're too poor to buy enough food
like they're stuck at zero and they
can't get out of it it's a really bad
scene because
first of all that's a lot of suffering
and that's not so good
second of all well at least in principle
a lot of those people might be
what might have something to offer the
world or their children might and you
want
to open up avenues of opportunity to
them so that they can succeed but so
that everyone else can benefit from
their success
so and then the next thing is well if
the inequality gets out of hand too much
then the whole society starts to
destabilize because if you get enough
people stacked up at zero
especially young men you get enough
young men stacked up at zero they think
oh to hell with it we'll just flip the
whole board over and
it'll settle in a new configuration and
maybe we won't be stuck at zero in the
new configuration
so it foments revolutionary thinking so
there's lots of reasons to be concerned
about inequality
and so you need a voice on the left to
say look we gotta parameterize the the
tendency towards inequality so that it
doesn't destabilize the entire society
so that it's
everybody has an opportunity to advance
like yes
right you need that okay so that's the
technical reason for the
necessity of the left and then i think
it's attractive because
well because young people can be
resentful partly because they're at the
bottom of the heap so to speak
they're not because they're young like
look you want to be
you want to be poor in 18 you want to be
rich in 80.
are going to choose most people is going
to take poor at 18. well
yeah especially if you've been rich at
80 and you understand you can get back
there
yeah well that's the thing you know is
that most of the people who are
have a million dollars or more in the
united states are old
well why is that well really do we need
an explanation for that it's like
you've had a lot more time to make money
how would that be that's the explanation
so that's one of the big drivers of
inequality is just simply age
but it's not obvious that the old rich
people have an advantage over the young
starting out people so so anyways but
any anyhow
maybe you're resentful and irritated
because you're young and you're still at
the bottom of the heap and
you know you've got other problems too
it's more difficult for people of your
race or ethnicity or gender at least you
think it is
and so you say well i want to make
things fair
and then that's also driven by some real
compassion because nobody really likes
that
the consequences of radical inequality
like nobody likes the fact that homeless
people
exist and have to go to the emergency
ward you know to get
treated and they don't have medical
coverage and they have to live in tents
on the street
and so if you have some compassion then
you think well we've got to do more for
the
poor and dispossessed it's like okay
that's that's an
understandable sentiment but the problem
is is that the people
but the problem is is that it's
that that that desire to help is
contaminated by resentment and
ideological certainty and then also by
something that george orwell
pointed out so nicely in his book road
to wigan pier
it's like the typical middle class
socialist this was his diagnosis and he
was a socialist by the way
his diagnosis was the typical middle
class intellectual socialist
doesn't like the poor in fact they don't
have anything to do with the poor
they're contemptuous of the poor but
they hate the rich
and i think it's even more devious than
that because i think who they hate are
the successful
some of the successful are rich but
really who they hate is the successful
it's it's like cain and abel it's the
retelling of cain and abel
and so there's some positive motivations
for being engaged on the left and
there's a lot of negative motivations as
well and
the people who are really driven by the
radical left ideology the real radicals
they're almost all driven by by
resentment and hatred as far as i'm
concerned
now the let's look at
both extremes so back to the idea of the
of the ideological and verbal territory
i said with bill c-16 that i wouldn't
speak the language of the radical
leftists because i don't think that that
language should define the game
but let's say it does so here's the game
the world is a battleground of
groups and the they're battling for
power
that's it that's the game and some of
them win and they oppress those who
don't win
so that's how we're going to view the
world okay now the left is say
okay well here's the oppressed people
the oppressors
the patriarchy type patriarchal types
they should be ashamed of themselves
and give up some power the right wingers
the radical right-wingers look at that
and they say
oh i see so the game is ethnic identity
is it it's
it's identity politics okay we're white
males
we're not going to lose that's the right
wing version of identity politics it's
like screw you
if we're going to divide into groups if
we're going to divide into tribes
and i'm in my tribe i'm not going to get
all guilty and lose
i'm going to get all cruel and win
and that's like then you think well
there's people in the middle they're
kind of looking back and forth which
side of the identity politics spectrum
am i going to fall in
do i want to go with uh do i want to go
do i want to be driven primarily by
compassion and am i going to accept
guilt for my historical privilege
so that's one possibility and then i'm
the oppressor i'm the member of the
oppressor group
or am i going to say no to hell with
that i'm just going to play to win well
then i'm going to go to the right
it's like well my sense is how about we
don't play either of those games
and the reason we shouldn't play them is
well the soviets played the left-wing
game
and like killed who knows how many tens
of millions of people you can't even
count it
accurately the estimates range from 20
to 100 million
those are pretty big error bars and the
maoists
may be 100 million certainly 60 million
so okay that didn't work out so well
then there's the nazis like they played
ethnic identity politics and racial
superiority it's like what do we
want to play that game see what i've
been trying to do
really what i've been trying to do for
the last 30 years is say look
there's heavy temptations to play those
sorts of games
but that's not the only game in town
it's a much better game to play
individual it's like get your act
together stand up in the world
make something of yourself stay away
from the ideological oversimplifications
set your house in order that's rule six
in the in the in this book so i have a
book
rule in there says set your house in
perfect order before you criticized the
world and it's a
very dark chapter about the motivations
of the columbine high school killers and
this other guy named carl panzram who
was a serial rapist and
arsonist and murderer and these he wrote
an autobiography and the columbine kids
also wrote about why they did what they
did
they're resentful to the core bitter
bitter resentful
terrible and
well i'm suggesting that people stay
away from that resentment resentfulness
and bitterness even though life is hard
and and there's malevolence in the world
it's like yeah
you can you can tell a story where
everyone's a victim
because we all die we all get sick you
know
and and and things happen to us that are
bitter and terrible betrayal deceit lies
like people hurt us
on purpose you know so it's not just the
tragedy of life
it's malevolence as well it's everyone's
a victim you can tell that story
the problem is if you tell that story
and you start to act it out you make all
of that worse
that's the problem and it's so this is
why partly i got attracted to
christian imagery at least in part um
because there's an idea in christianity
that you should pick up your goddamn
cross and like walk
up the hill and that's
dramatically that's correct that's the
right answer it's like
you've got a heavy load of suffering to
bear and a fair bit of it's going to be
unjust
so what are you going to do about it
accept it voluntarily
and try to transform as a consequence
that's the right answer
it's the right answer because the rest
of it is tribalism and
we're we're too technologically powerful
to get all tribal again
what's exciting to me is that i think
this is the first time in my
life that i've ever seen so much
communication on these subjects
and i think so much recognition about
the consequences of tribal
toxic tribalism this tribal thinking
that everyone seems to be engaged in on
the right and on the left
i mean in america you need to go no
further than going back and forth from
cnn to fox news
to say something's wrong here these are
these are supposed to be news outlets
you have two completely different
narratives
and that has nothing to do with what
we're talking about with gender politics
and
and radical left socialism and marxism
what what you're seeing in universities
though
um is a radical departure
from what i always considered
universities
great for what i always considered
universities great
for is separating from your parents
challenging belief systems and being
engaged
in the the works of brilliant people
who you can compare all of their
findings and their discoveries and and
sit down and debate them in class and
when i was a kid when i was in high
school i went to a very good high school
newton south high school
in newton massachusetts and uh one of
the
things that they did is they put on a
debate between a guy from the moral
majority which was this uh
right-wing uh christian group
that i don't even know if they're around
anymore but there this was 19
i was 14 so 81 and uh barney frank
who was that congressman is now one of
the first openly gay guys
uh in congress and and uh
you got to watch these two people in
this auditorium
debate their points and this moral
majority guy had this
you know right wing ronald reagan sort
of
puke point of view and barney franco's
kind of crazy
he's got busted in some male prostitute
scandal and
but the gay community that's not that
big of a deal and uh
just barney frank took him apart it was
brilliant to watch but it was a real
debate it was fascinating and he got to
see
a a mediocre mind versus a great mind
and
he got to see this little thing and i
was like wow this is one of the things
that's
always attracted me about the
the idea that two people with differing
viewpoints
can get together in front of a neutral
audience and these people can sort of
decipher
which which way these people are
thinking and why they're thinking yeah
well
and bad as that is and rife with
conflict as that is
the alternative is to separate as you
pointed out into two camps that don't
talk
yes and the thing is the the consequence
of not talking
is that you fight that that's the end
game because the only way you can stop
from fighting with other people is by
negotiating with them
and you know one of the things that's
also interesting and this is partly why
silicon valley leans to the left is that
a fair bit of your political
preference is determined by your
biological temperament
it's strongly influenced so if you're a
creative type
who's kind of disorderly then you're
likely to be
on the liberal left end of the
distribution and if you're a
non-creative type who's orderly and
especially if you're orderly then you
tend to be on the right wing end of
things
and so and well why is that why do those
variations exist well
they exist because some of the time your
best strategy is to do what other people
have done and shut the hell up and just
do it run the algorithm
right the pathway is already laid clear
it works
stay in the damn rut and move forward
okay so that's the conservative approach
and when things are going right it's the
right approach
the problem is is that sometimes it's
not the right approach because something
has shifted
and so something new has to emerge and
so then there's a bunch of people who
are adapted to the new
and those are the entrepreneurial and
creative types and of course they
dominate silicon valley because it's a
very entrepreneurial it's a very
entrepreneurial
what would you call it um geography and
so
they're going to lean to the left but
they have to understand people have to
understand that the left and the right
need each other the liberals and the
conservatives need each other
liberals start companies conservatives
run them
and the problem with the conservatives
is well they can only run a company in
one direction
because they're conservative they don't
think outside the box
but so if the company is working and the
product line is good and everything is
stable like
hire some conservatives because they'll
maximize efficiency and they'll move
down that track
but if the track is no longer going in a
good direction
because something's changed the
environments change well then you've got
to bring in the creative people
and so we need each other and the only
way that we can survive
the fact that we're different and the
fact that we need each other is by
continually talking we have talked
constantly it's like
well how much of what we're doing should
we preserve
versus how much of what we're doing
should we transform and the answer is
we don't know because the environment
keeps changing so what do we do about
that
we talk oh i was on a cbc canadian
broadcasting
corporation interview a couple of days
ago and they took me to task
i tweeted out this uh this invitation to
the keck boys
to fill out this program that i
developed called future authoring and
it helps people make a position yeah
well they're
they're an online group they're they're
they i know what it is
it's this fictional polity it's a it's a
satire of identity politics
essentially we're going to we're going
to be our ethnicity
highly demonized satire highly demonized
right and with good reason for with some
individual examples of racism and
nazism and you know yeah there's lots of
misbehavior yeah yeah yeah
it's like graffiti it's like online
graffiti something like that
so um and and
the keck boys are the ones who are often
using the peppy memes for example and
you know the left regards pepe as a hate
symbol pepe the frog
pepe the frog feels good frog that's
right that's right kind of reprehensible
frog
and so i tweeted out to them i said
keck boys seek your 4chan
rescue yourself from the underworld use
code pepe
for future authoring so it's free for
one week so
i they had to figure out what it meant
and then i showed this picture of
michigan j frog which is the frog from
old warner brothers cartoon dancing frog
that wouldn't perform when anyone was
watching it
so cbc hauled that out and said well
look aren't you
aren't you like um appealing to the
radical right and i said well no what
i'm doing i said look the
these people are attracted by the
radical right although they're satirists
and
juvenile satirists and graffiti types
and you know they're they're playing a
weird sense
that's exactly what they're doing
they're they're provoking and i my sense
was
well why don't you develop yourself as
an individual and get the hell out of
the ideological trap
so here's my program which helps you
write about your future
and that'll help you decide who you are
as an individual because
that's the way out of the ideological
trap it's like and that's the way
obviously what's the way out of
tribalism first
the way out of tribalism is not to never
join a tribe
you actually have to join a tribe as you
mature right because what happens is
first of all you're an infant and then
you have your parents to
to make a relationship with but then
when you move from your parents
you have your tribe you have your group
maybe it's the music you listen to it's
the gang you hang around with whatever
you have to be socialized into the tribe
you have to
because otherwise you stay a dependent
infant okay but now you're socialized
into the tribe
well is that where it ends it's like no
the next thing to do is
differentiate yourself from the tribe
while still knowing how to behave within
the
tribe well that's the call to
individualism and that's i think what
the west got right is we figured that
out it's like
you're more than you're you have to be a
member of a group because otherwise
you're not socialized you're not good
for anyone you don't have to be able to
play on a team man
you have to have team loyalty okay but
that isn't where you should stop you
should
take the next step and become a fully
developed individual and
see the problem with being just a group
member is that the group
it's the problem with conservatism the
group is a fixed entity
it has its rules and its regulations and
if you're a member that's all you are
but the group can go badly wrong so the
group needs individuals to keep the
group alive and revivified
so you have to become an individual so
you can revivify the group
that's the cult that's the call in the
west to heroism essentially to
noble way of living is to develop
yourself past your group identity
so that you can reconfigure the game
when that becomes necessary
and i think that there's a very
influential line of developmental
psychology
uh pioneered by jean piaget that laid
that out as a developmental
what would progression first you're
a child then you're a member of a group
then you're an individual it's like get
to the individual level
that's the solution it's a solution to
tribalism but you have to accept
responsibility to do that
and this is what your future authoring
program is basically all about i mean
it's it's a wonderful program it's and
along with this book rules and
guidelines for life i think that's one
of the things that a lot of young people
are lacking
is a structure to how to go about
establishing
who they are in the world yeah well
that's
you know what's really cool and it's
been really quite remarkable i would say
is that what i've noticed when i've been
speaking publicly say over the last year
and a half
because there's a hole in our culture
where there
should be a discussion about maturity
truth and responsibility
no one's talking about that okay so now
i'll come up and i'll start talking
about that i'll say look like
what should you do with your life um
well take care of yourself
but take care of yourself in a way that
also means that simultaneously you're
taking care of your family
and that and also means that
simultaneously you're taking care of the
broader community so that's kind of your
goal so orient yourself towards that
personal success but in a way that your
success
breeds success because if you're going
to establish a name why not establish
like a really good aim that's a good one
it's good for you it's good for everyone
else
yes okay that'll give your life some
meaning now adopt
make a plan generate a vision that's
what the future authoring program helps
people with make a
develop a vision of what your life could
be like if if it was worth living
despite all its suffering it's like what
would you need so that you would be
happy to be alive
you'd find your life meaningful so you
don't get all bitter and resentful and
cruel and hostile and ideologically
adult and
like murderous and genocidal it's like
none of that
you think real hard how would you have
to configure your life so that despite
its suffering and the malevolence that's
part of it that you would regard
it as worthwhile so that's up to you to
develop a vision
then put a plan into practice and so
when i talk to people about this
and most of my audiences are young men
it's probably about 65 35 more and more
women are showing up but that's about
what it is right now
the halls are dead silent you could hear
a pin drop
because nobody's said so clearly for
like 50 years that
almost all the meaning that you will
need to get you through the hard times
of your life
is going to be a consequence of adopting
responsibility not of rights and
impulsive
action impulsive freedom like
fine rights yeah got it freedom
no problem even freedom to do impulsive
things fine
but that isn't where you're going to
find the meaning that keeps you
sustained
through the storms of life that's going
to be
you take care of yourself you take care
of your intimate partner you take care
of your damn
family you don't run off you take care
of your community
you rescue the wisdom from the past you
stand up straight and you be courageous
despite the fact that life is tragic
and tainted by malevolence it's like
that's the that's
ancient wisdom that's what that is and
understanding that there's structure and
discipline
and that you know i am in a lot of ways
both of those things you described
earlier i'm in a lot of ways
my mind is i'm creative and i'm always
sort of half paying attention to things
but i'm also disciplined yeah right
and it's one of the reasons why i think
i'm i so relate to both sides of this
issue
yeah because i could it's also one of
the reasons you're successful yeah i
could have easily been
some hardcore right-wing [ __ ] i'm a
competition-oriented person
i've been since i was a child yeah i
grew up
competing in martial arts tournaments i
mean that's and you
have to be a hard person to do that you
have to understand what discipline is
but before that i was an artist i wanted
to be a cartoonist i wanted to
do comic books that's what i wanted to
do i wanted to be an illustrator
if it wasn't for one bad teacher in high
school that totally shied me away from
art
i probably would have went into that as
a living
when i look at both sides i see myself
in both sides
yep yep well the other thing i've been
telling young men is that
and and this is something i think that
you could relate to tremendously is
i read this new testament line well
decades ago and i could never understand
it it's the line is the meek shall
inherit the earth
and i thought there's something wrong
with that that line it just doesn't make
sense to me meat just doesn't seem to me
to be a moral virtue
and so i did a series of biblical
lectures this year
like 15 of them and that was also a
weird little experience that we can talk
about
but i was looking through the these
these sayings these maxims and that was
one of them
the meek shall inherit the earth but
i've been using this site called bible
hub and it's very interesting it's very
it's organized very
interesting so you have a biblical line
and then they
they have like three pages of commentary
on each line
and so because people have commented on
every verse in the bible like
to the to degree that's almost
unimaginable so you can look and see
all the interpretations and all the
translations and get some sense of what
the
genuine meaning might be and the line
the meek shall inherit the earth meek is
not
a good translation or the word has moved
in the 300 years or so
300 years or so since it was translated
what it means is this
those who have swords and know how to
use them but keep them
sheathed will inherit the world and
that's another thing i've been telling
you yeah no kidding that's a lot
different
that's a big difference it's so great
and so like one of the things i tell
young men
well on young women as well but the
young men really need to hear this more
i think is that
you should be a monster you know because
everyone says well you should be
harmless virtuous you shouldn't do
anyone any harm you should sheath your
competitive instinct you shouldn't try
to win
you know you you don't want to be too
aggressive you don't want to be too
assertive you want to take a back seat
and all of that it's like
no wrong you should be a monster
an absolute monster and then you should
learn how to control it
do you know the expression it's better
to be a warrior in a garden than a
gardener in a war
right right exactly that's exactly it
yeah yeah and that's exactly right and
so when i tell young men that they think
well lots of them are competitive
they're low in agreeableness you know
because that's part of being competitive
temperamentally
it's like is there something wrong with
being competitive there's nothing wrong
with it
there's something wrong with cheating
there's something wrong with being a
tyrant
there's something wrong with winning
unfairly all of those things are bad
but you don't want people to win what's
the difference between trying to win and
striving
you want to eradicate striving what's
the uncomfortable feeling that people
associate with losing
when they've personally experienced it
they look at losing as their
they've been oppressed or they've been
hurt but what they don't understand is
that is the motivation for growth
and one of the most beautiful things
that i think a young person can get
involved in
is martial arts because martial arts
teach you that in a way that very few
things do
they teach you it in especially jiu
jitsu because jiu jitsu is so complex
and there's so many possibilities to it
that it attracts a lot of really smart
people
if you think of jujitsu you would think
of like brutish individuals engaging in
this hard martial art
you go to a real good jujitsu school you
see nerds
you see a bunch of like really smart
kids that really get obsessed with the
possibilities of this physical language
this physical language also teaches you
the consequences of
not working hard of not being prepared
of not understanding positions of not
doing due diligence and doing the work
and it's it's an amazing
amazing scaffolding for developing your
life but it also teaches you how to lose
yes you know and that's very important
one definition of a winner is
someone who never let losing stop them
yes you know and and the idea that
a single loss in the competition is
somehow a defeat is completely insane
first of all well let's say you're a
hockey player and you're a good player
and you
you lose the tournament it's like well
so what you played the game
you're increasing your skills it's like
there's always next time
and one of the things that i've also
been
telling people informing people about is
the idea that life isn't a game
it's a series of games and the right
ethic is to be the winner of the series
of games
and part of that means you all you have
to learn how to be a good loser because
you're not going to win every single
game
but you also have to embrace those
losses as learning experiences
and the people that have never lost or
afraid of losing they're afraid of
learning
you're afraid of that feeling that
terrible feeling that you get from
losing
is so beneficial it's aided me in so
many ways like it's one of the reasons
and also one of the reasons why i talk
so openly about bombing on stage
and i do it with other comedians i i
always want to tell people yeah
i'm an established comedian i've been a
comedian for a long time let me tell you
about like when i was two years in or
five years in or
or four years ago like can we tell you
about some horrible
moments on stage where it went wrong
just so you understand like those things
took me to another place because i
realized i don't want to ever feel that
feeling again
and so i ramped everything up and then i
went back to work and i went over my
notebooks and i went over my
my recordings and i figured out what i
was doing wrong and
and i tried to improve upon it but if it
wasn't for that horrible sick feeling
that's the same feeling you get when you
get tapped out in jiu jitsu class
same feeling you get when you lose a
martial arts tournament or anything else
losing is important well you might also
say like
let's say that you could pick your le
you can pick your level of competition
in life to some degree
okay so let's say you pick a level of
competition where you're always winning
it's like well all that means is you've
picked the wrong level of competition
yes
because you know like let's say you're a
grandmaster
chess player and you're all you do is
play amateurs and every night you go
home and congratulate yourself on what a
genius you are because you just stomp
these people left right and center it's
like you're not a genius
you're dimwit right what you should be
doing is playing people who are beating
you like
well as much as you can tolerate right
so maybe that's 40
of the time maybe it's 60 percent of the
time but that way
because to be a winner you want to be
disciplined you want to know what you're
doing and then you want to be on the
edge
where your skills are being developed
and if you're going to be on the edge
where your skills are going to be
developed
you're you're at a place where where
loss we're losing is always a
possibility
because otherwise you're not pushing
yourself beyond your current capacity
and so one of the things that i've
outlined in 12 rules for life is
is a theory of meaning because meaning
as far as i'm concerned the sense of
meaningful engagement is the antidote to
malevolence and suffering essentially
because you want to have a life that's
so engaging that you think despite the
fact that i'm limited and
that we're mortal and that life is
tragedy and there's evil in the world
despite all that
this is worth doing and i think that
that there's there's a there's a
technical
meaning that that that genuinely exists
and that's the meaning that you get when
you're
in a domain where you have some
discipline and some skill so you're
laying out your competence and
and your your ability but you're
simultaneously pushing yourself
to develop past where you are that's
really engrossing
and what's that do it what that is doing
is expanding your competence and so
life is suffering and betrayal in
in in many senses of the world but you
can adopt a way of traversing through
life
that is more powerful than the tragedy
in the malevolence
i agree and i say to many people that
what
what is going on in your life is you
have a series of human reward systems
that are
in your body encoded in your body in
your genetics
and it's the reason why human beings
survive to 2018.
in in order to be happy you have to feed
those things you have to feed all of
them you have to feed the one that
wants to uh overcome difficult tasks
you have to feed the one that wants to
solve problems you have to feed the one
that wants to be
with a loving tribe of people that you
care about you have to feed the one that
wants to procreate
you have to feed all these things you
have to feed the love you have to feed
the competition
you have to feed the discipline and that
to me is the only way to stay balanced
or
with me with my body and my mind that's
the only way i've
i've been able to stay balanced and when
either one any of those things get out
of whack
i get out of whack yeah well so so part
of that is so imagine this so imagine
that you're this
loose collection of all these things
that need to be gratified that need to
be fed it's a
perfectly reasonable way of looking at
it biologically okay so now
you have to conjure up a mode of being
that satisfies
all those necessities simultaneously but
then
and this is this is a technical
explanation of why the post-modernist
insistence that there's an infinite
number of explanations
turns out to be wrong an infinite number
of interpretations
there's a very finite number of viable
interpretations
so the first constraint is what exactly
what you just said
you have these inner demons let's say
all of which need to be satisfied
but they need to be satisfied in a very
particular way not only do they need to
be satisfied today
but they need to be satisfied today in a
way that doesn't interfere with
satisfying them next week next month
next year and in a decade
so because there's no point in you
betraying your
your future self to gratify your present
self right it's a stupid game
okay so you're constrained by the
necessity of satisfying yourself but of
maintaining that satisfaction across
time
but then it gets even worse that's hard
enough but it's like there's an
infinite number of views extending
indefinitely into the future and all of
them have to be satisfied simultaneously
but then it's worse because it isn't
just you you have to figure out how to
gratify all those internal demons in a
sustainable way
in a way that other people not only
don't object to
but probably help you with and that
benefits them at the same time
well then you think you think well there
just aren't that many ways of solving
that problem and we know some of them
one of them is
reciprocity you know like if you go out
of your way for me
it's incumbent on me to notice that and
to attempt in some manner to
to repay you and like if if we're good
friends that's what we'll do if we're
good
brothers that's what we'll do that's
what you do with your wife it's a
reciprocal arrangement
and that keeps things flowing properly
across time
so there is an there is an ethic this
and this is the answer to the
post-modern conundrum it's like well is
life meaningless
is everything just nihilist is is
nihilism the
right answer or maybe you know the what
would you call
identification with an ideology as a
counter position to nihilism so nihilism
is wrong
life is meaningful that and that's what
12 rules for life is about
the first meaning of life is suffering
and malevolence
there's indisputable realities okay
well what's what's after that well
there's a noble way of being that allows
you to
exist properly despite that
and also not to make it worse so can
your life be meaningful enough so that
you
what is it confront chaos
voluntarily establish and revivify
order constrain malevolence
that's a good three-part doctrine for
life
there's things to do and so that's what
i've been talking to the audiences that
i've been
seeing over the last year it's like get
your act together stand up forthrightly
that's rule one stand up straight with
your shoulders back
there's a vulnerable position right
because you're open but it's a powerful
position because it means that you're
brave enough to take what's coming
and it isn't like what's coming isn't
dangerous
it's dangerous so but your best bet is
to be
dancing on your feet and ready for it
pay attention and be awake
and to treat yourself properly that's
rule two is figure out how to treat
yourself as if you're someone
worth coming to the aid of to detach
yourself in a bit and say okay i'm going
to set up my life so that
it it's good for me and good for other
people as well
that's a corollary to that so the book
is all about
all about the meanings of life
the negative meanings suffering
malevolence those are indisputable
realities
and then a motive being that integrates
the sorts of things that you were
talking about these underlying needs
with everyone else's and like doing that
voluntarily it's a call to
responsibility and meaning
and i actually think it's not the thing
that's been so exciting for me
for the last three decades looking into
these things is that
i believe that there is a genuine
human ethic it's not arbitrary it has to
do with reciprocity for example it has
to do with honesty that's another thing
is that
speak the truth because your life turns
out better if you speak the truth and so
does everyone else's
so in this biblical lecture series i did
i looked at the first chapter in genesis
and there's a theory in there it's
really interesting theory
and the theory is that there's three
parts to being there's chaos and
potential
and that would be like the potential you
should live up to because everyone says
well
you should live up to your potential
it's like what the hell's that you can't
measure it
or touch it or taste it feel it it's
this hypothetical thing that everyone
regards as real it's like
it's like the future what's the future
well it's not here yet you can't measure
it what makes you think it's real
well we act as if it's real and that
seems to work
there's the so there's potential that's
one that's chaos chaotic potential
then there's order and that's the
structure that you need in order to
to confront the chaos and and you'd be
born with that biologically and then
there's
your ability to to call forth from the
potential
new order that's what you do with your
speech and that's what that's what
happens in the first chapter of genesis
is that
god uses god's order let's say
uses the power of truthful speech that's
the logos to transform potential into
order
and that's what people are made in the
image of so there's this
theory it's a lovely theory that's laid
out right at the beginning of the bible
that says that
if you tell the truth you transform the
potential
of being into a habitable actuality
that's how it works so say well how do
you wanna how do you make the world
better
tell the truth because the world you
bring into being
as a consequence of telling the truth
will be a good world
and i believe that's true i think it's
true metaphorically
i think it's true theologically and i
think it's true
like at the practical and scientific
level as well i think it's true in all
those levels simultaneously
so that's been ridiculously exciting to
to sort through
i think this notion and one of the
things that you said that i think really
resonates is that
there's not a voice out there that is
advocating for responsibility and that
is
talking about how important this is and
i think this is an inherent principle
that most people are kind of aware of
and it feels good to them to hear like
it resonates
you feel it you when you when you're
saying this clean your room
you know put your house in order people
like yeah yeah how come i'm not hearing
this right
right i'm not hearing this well it's so
funny because one of the things
psychologists have done for the last 20
years
especially the social psychologists is
push this idea of self-esteem
you should feel good about yourself and
i think why would you tell someone 20
that
it's like you should feel good about who
you are it's like no you shouldn't why
should you feel good about who you are
it's like you should feel good about who
you could be that's way better because
you've got 60 years to turn into who you
go
wait a minute are you what your
accomplishments are or are you this
individual going through this journey
i mean i don't think there's anything
wrong with feeling good about who you
are if
as long as it's tempered by an
understanding of potential and
what you have accomplished versus what
you can accomplish well i think
but having confidence is a big part of
it it is it is and i'm not saying that
people shouldn't have confidence but
like often you take young people say
they're 16 to 22
and they're not really feeling that good
about who they are right because their
life is
chaotic and in disorder and they don't
know where they're going and they don't
know which way is up
also there could be bad parenting
bullying that could be a lot of abuse
going on
and i think that's one of the reasons
why that resonates with people this idea
of
be happy for you about who you are right
feel good about who you're right but but
the thing is it has to be
stated with precision it's like yes it's
like
you should you should treat yourself as
if you're valuable
especially in potential but you should
concentrate on who you should become
especially if you're young and so let's
say you're miserable and nihilistic and
chaotic and depressed and all of that
now and you have your reasons you know
terrible parenting abuse all of those
things it's like well
you should feel good about yourself it's
like no no it's not it's not the right
message is that
it's more like you should understand how
much potential there is within you to
set that straight
and then you should do everything you
can to manifest that in the world and it
will set it straight
and that's better than self-esteem it's
like you're you're in a crooked horrible
position
okay fine there's a lot of suffering and
pain associated with that yeah
you can't just feel good about that
because it's not good but you can do
something about it you can genuinely do
something about it
and i think all the evidence suggests
that that's the case yes
so i'm telling telling young people look
there's no matter how bad your situation
is
i'm not going to pretend it's okay it's
not okay it's tragic
tainted with malevolence and some people
really get hurt by malevolent people
like
you know terribly hurt sometimes they
never recover it's really awful
but there's more to you than you think
and if you stand up and face it
with with a positive with a with a noble
vision
with discipline and intent you can go
far farther to overcoming it than you
can imagine
and that's the principle upon which you
should predicate your behavior
and i think that one of the things
that's really nice about being a
clinical psychologist is that
this isn't just guesswork like one of
the things we know two things in
clinical psychology one is
truthful conversations redeem people
because if you come to a clinical
psychologist whose worth is solved
you have a truthful conversation the
conversation is
well here's what's wrong with my life
and here's what caused it you know maybe
it takes a year to have that
conversation and
both of the participants are doing
everything they can to lay it out
properly
here's how it might be fixed here's what
a beneficial future might look like
and so it's a completely honest
conversation if it's working well
and all that's happening in the
conversation is that the two people
involved
are trying to make things better that's
the goal let's see if we can have a
conversation that will make things
better okay so we know that works it
does make things better
and then another thing we know is that
well let's say there's a bunch of things
that you're afraid of that are in your
way
so you have some vision about who you
want to be maybe you have to you know
you want to be successful in your career
so you have to learn to talk in front of
a group it's like okay well you're
afraid of that
it's like no wonder you don't want to be
humiliated so okay so what do we do
about that
well maybe we first get you to speak in
front of one person and then three
people
you know for five minutes and then for
10 minutes like graduated exposure to
what you're afraid of voluntary
graduated exposure to what you're afraid
of
is curative and that's true it works
the documentation is in it's how people
learn so
so to to to tell people that if you
confront the world forthrightly
if you speak the truth and you expose
yourself courageously to those things
that you're afraid of
that your life will improve and so will
the life of people around you
like as far as i'm concerned that's as
close to undeniable fact as we
as we've got and it also dovetails
nicely with the underlying archetypal
stories the heroic stories it's like go
out there
find the dragon confront it it's a
dragon it might eat you it's dangerous
but it's worse to cower at home and wait
for it to come and devour you
go out there confront it get the gold
share it with the community it's like
yeah it's the oldest story of mankind i
think one
of the factors and the resistance to
these ideas of discipline
and of taking responsibility for
yourself and of a lot of the things that
you've been saying in regards to
you know all the things that we
discussed earlier is people recognizing
that they're not doing that in their own
lives and they get upset
and instead of looking internally they
try to attack the thing
that's upsetting them they attack your
message
they attack the philosophy behind it
rather than look internally
and objectively and having some sort of
introspective
point of view where you go okay am i
reacting to this because this
resonates like i'm missing this aspect
of my life
is this guy does does does this diminish
me
or is this guy pointing something out
that i can benefit from
very few people are willing to do that
very few people are willing to take that
critical moment
to look at their own behavior and look
at their own thought process and wonder
if
the actual adverse reaction they have to
this person's message
is because they know that they're wrong
yeah well it's no well
it's there's a couple of reasons for
that one is well
what makes you think that you're someone
we should listen to
it's like fair enough you know so you've
got to be poked a bunch to see if that's
true
and then the next thing is um well
it's it's painful to understand
how much of what you're doing isn't
productive so i'll give you an example
so i've done this a couple of times with
classrooms full of students
usually when i'm lecturing about career
development say okay
how much time do you waste so then i get
the class to vote how many of you waste
uh
10 hours a day it's like 10 percent of
the kids will put up their hands
and it's interesting because i don't
define what constitutes waste
i just ask the question so they're
diagnosing themselves right i'm not
saying you're wasting 10 hours a day
i'm just asking it's like given your own
attitude
how much time are you wasting 10 hours a
day it's like 10 of the people put up
their hands
well when you get to like six hours a
day eighty percent of the people put up
their hands
so then we do the arithmetic it's like
because i like doing arithmetic with
people
people hate arithmetic but i like doing
it it's like okay
six hours a day it's 42 hours a week so
let's call that a work week 40 hours a
week
so so that's that's a work week let's
say what's your time worth
your university student well it's
certainly worth minimum wage
because obviously but it's worth way
more than that because
if you spend a productive hour when
you're 20 then you gain the benefits of
that hour for the rest of your life so
there's the compounding effect of
time spent when you're young so i say
well let's assume your time's worth 50
bucks an hour
which i think is an underestimate but
whatever let's call it 50. we call it 25
but we'll call it 50.
that's two thousand dollars a week
you're wasting it's a hundred thousand
dollars a year
it's like how much better would your
life be if you weren't wasting a hundred
thousand dollars a year
it's like what is that over forty years
four million dollars
it's like you're rich you don't even
know it quit wasting time
by your own definition it's like people
shake their heads like i never thought
about it that way it's like yeah
think about it that way don't waste your
damn life and
then you think why would people be
resistant to that message it's like well
you really want to wake up and figure
out that you're wasting half your life
and you know when people do that kind of
wasting they actually hate it
you know and i've had lots of people
come to my clinical practice who were
chronic procrastinators
you know and so they're watching youtube
videos say
but but not ones that are good for them
although sometimes they will do that but
just
browsing in that kind of mindless way
that you do when you're not paying
attention and you're trying to kill time
and people doing that they feel bad they
get depressed they feel anxious they
can't get away from it they feel kind of
quasi-addicted
what are they doing about social media
now it's a huge issue with young kids
absolutely but there's this feeling of
kind of internal
rot and corruption that goes along with
it it's like yeah well you're wasting
your life
it's like so it's painful it's painful
to recognize that
then it's painful to think oh my god
look how undisciplined i am
i don't know anything i can't use a
schedule i can't i can't stick to a
calendar
i don't have any aims i don't know
anything about the world
right and maybe there's a part of me
that's bitter because i haven't got
everything already and i'd like just
like to say to hell with it
that's the recognition of the union's
shadow it's like that's what makes you
vicious and
and and and untrustworthy all of that no
one wants to look at that
and no bloody wonder but
hey the alternative is worse so the
problem is you say like
just saying you stop wasting your life
like i think that
that's not enough i think this is one of
the reasons why a book like this is so
important like the idea of
discipline in most people's eyes it's
like if you're not a disciplined person
it's uncomfortable it's it's going to be
painful
it's it's frustrating you you have to
force yourself into these things
it's a muscle it's a and it's a muscle
that has to be developed these patterns
have to be developed in
in your own mind incrementally yes yeah
well with uh
so you're right just telling people not
to waste their lives is not enough and
this is another reason why i've
so much enjoyed being a clinical
psychologist because clinical
psychologists don't
stick with high-level abstractions
especially the behaviors they're really
practical it's like okay you want to get
your act together it's like well
how about if let's say you're not
studying
well and so we do a real analysis of how
much you're studying you say well i go
to the library four hours a day it's
like yeah yeah okay
how much time do you actually study in
the library well
you know i waste time i have to travel
there i look at my phone it's like okay
well
how much 15 minutes half an hour how
much is real studying
well maybe we figure out it's 15 minutes
so okay so what you're going to do for
one week
is you're going to study for half an
hour that's all you don't get to go to
the library for four hours
you have to sit down we'll figure out a
time 10 o'clock in the morning whatever
we'll put it in your schedule try to
study for half an hour no more
and then just come back and let's have a
conversation about how well that worked
and people come back and they say well
you know i managed it four days
and one day i went over and one day i
couldn't do it at all it's like okay
that's better instead of 75 minutes of
studying
you know 15 minutes a day for seven days
what is that 15
70 105 minutes you've managed about 210
minutes so you've already produced an
improvement of 50 percent
in your bumbling horrible way you got a
50 improvement in one week
it's like that's deadly it's like so in
in the future authoring program
what we ask people to do is well think
about your life along six dimensions
what do you want for your so the goal is
this you're going to take care of
yourself
you're going to have a life in three
years that justifies its suffering
that's the goal so you can invent the
damn life but you have to think what you
would be satisfied with so you wouldn't
be all bitter and resentful
it's like okay what do you want from
your family what do you want from your
friends
how are you going to educate yourself
what do you want for your career how are
you going to use your time outside of
work how are you going to handle drugs
and alcohol and other temptations like
that
how are you going to keep yourself
mentally and physically healthy these
are open questions like you get to
answer them
the idea is you can have whatever you
want but you have to figure out what it
is it has to be realistic and you have
to figure out what it is
it's okay so now develop a vision what's
your life going to be like in three to
five years
so you write it down then we do
something else which is okay um
your bad habits and your resentment and
your bitterness and all of that your
procrastination gets completely out of
hand
and you auger down and you're in your
own personal version of hell in three to
five years
what does that look like well everyone
knows that it's like everyone can look
into the future and think well
if i keep going on this dark path this
is where i'll end up
well then you've got a little hell
outline for yourself to run away from
and you've got a little heaven outline
for yourself to run towards and then
you're motivated
because sometimes you know you're just
hopeful i would like a good thing to
happen it's like
yeah but you know i'd like to drink half
a bottle of whiskey tonight too it's
like
so which is it gonna be well just being
hopeful about the future might not be
enough but then you think oh
i see like there's that little hell
thing that i outlined that's waiting for
me
and maybe i'm afraid of taking the next
next step forward because it's demanding
and challenging it's like
yeah i'm afraid of that but i'm way more
afraid of where i might end up if i
don't get my act together
and people should be that's why there
are conceptions of hell in so many
religions
it's like hell is a real place whether
it's eternal that's a whole different
question
whether it's waiting for you in the
afterlife that's a whole different
question
but if you've never met anyone in hell
you haven't lived very long
you haven't had your eyes open yeah it's
undeniable that
that feeling of total complete misery is
undeniable
yeah especially when it's compounded by
the fact that you know you did it to
yourself
that's the real fun that's the real fun
part it's like i'm having a [ __ ] of a
time and i
richly deserve it jesus that's rough man
this
is another concept that is doesn't have
a voice right now
this is another i mean this is a giant
part of being a human being
and instead of identity politics and
right versus left i think
these these right versus left battles
oftentimes
what they are is simply the the
battleground for the conflicts in your
own mind
better to have the conflict in yourself
that's another thing i really learned
well
not not only from the new testament but
a fair bit from that
you know the idea is that well there's
evil in the world
of all sorts and some of it's the evil
in other people
and some of it's the evil in your
brother's heart
but the the part of it that you can
really do something about that's the
malevolence in your own heart
you can actually do something about that
and that's actually way more useful than
you think
so because if you can face it in you
then you start to understand it and that
also makes you strong enough to
identify it and to fight it when you see
it in the external world plus you don't
do any harm
it's like like there's lots of people
all over the world going out and doing
reprehensible things you might say well
you should go out and protest against
them
like then sometimes you should but most
of the time you should think
where am i falling short of the ideal my
own ideal
doesn't have to be one that someone puts
on you where am i less than i should be
where am i bitter where am i making the
world the worst place than it has to be
like you ask yourself those questions
you'll be in for a big shock
say well what would happen if you
stopped doing that that's what 12 rules
for life is about it's like
stop saying things that make you weak
stop telling lies
that you know to be lies stop doing
things you know to be useless and
counterproductive
aim high adopt some responsibility and
then see what the hell happens
it's like it'll work and that's what i'm
hoping people will do
yeah i'm hoping people do that too and i
think the if more people
live their life in this sort of a manner
i think we're going to have
less differences in terms of our
ideologies and more of an understanding
that people have different ways of
looking at things
and different ways of living and this
this combat between
people this this internal strife that
manifests itself
in this combat between ideologies i
think
you are much more inclined to let other
people live their lives if you're living
your life in a satisfactory manner
that's exactly it that's that i have a
chapter in there on raising kids
says uh don't like your kids don't let
your kids do anything that makes you
dislike them
it's like well that's first predicated
on the observation that you're quite a
monster and it would be better for your
kids if they didn't get on your bad side
and like again because i'm a clinical
psychologist i keep saying monster why
why do you use that term because i've
watched families
like i've seen families where it's as if
every single person in the family has
their hands around
the neck of the family member that's
close to them and they're squeezing
but only tight enough to strangle them
in 20 years but you're not always using
it as a pejorative you you you've also
used it you should become
a monster you should be a monster yeah
but that's that's
you shouldn't be it shouldn't be
accidental
that's the thing what so what do you
mean by monster then in a positive sense
like you should
a monster oh that's easy a positive
monster is somebody who says no and
means it
because when you say no what you mean is
there isn't anything you can do to me
that will make me agree to do this
why is that a monster because you have
to be because no one will take you
seriously otherwise
no one will take you seriously like no
means
if you keep pushing this something that
you do not like will happen to you
that's what no means you don't have any
strength of character unless you can put
up a fight
you know and to be able to say no to
something is to be able to put up a
fight
so and you can't do that if you're if
you can be pushed around
you'll just get argued into submission
or you'll feel guilty because you're
causing conflict or something like that
but isn't there confusion
using those terms as a positive as a
negative maybe there's another word
instead of monsters well there is there
is the potential there is the potential
for confusion you say well is that
something that can be
because i think that monster is a
horrible thing i don't think of it as
being like a wall
like someone who is just rock solid in
their belief system and
rocks out in their understanding well
when you when you fight someone who's
formidable say
what do you think of the person that
you're fighting like how would you
characterize them
they mean they have a monstrous side
because they can they they'll they can
they can bring physical
substantial physical force to bear on
the situation
and and be willing to do it so they're
not
naive and and harmless by any stretch of
the imagination right they have a
well-developed capacity for mayhem
they think well is that monstrous it's
like well
i would say yes i would say fierce
fierce fine let's go with that yeah
because someone
who's fierce and formidable it's not
necessarily a monster
you know just i think of a monster as
being just an awful person who's done
awful things and just
you know okay well so but fair enough
well so back to the back to the
situation with your kids well you
definitely don't want to have your kids
act in a way that awakens your inner
monster
right let's put it that way and so you
need to you need to
organize your family with a certain
amount of discipline and a certain
amount of structure so that you get to
do what you want which is back to
back to the point that you made earlier
so that you're happy to have your kids
around
so that you won't take revenge on them
and so you want to
lay your life out so that
well so that it's providing you what you
need
to not be bitter and to work for your
best interests and for the interests of
everyone else
that would be lovely and i think it's
attainable you know because
the book is very dark and i'm a very
dark guy in some ways because i've
looked at
the terrible things that people do to
one another that's the fascinating way
of looking at it you think you're
yourself as dark cause i don't
oh that's great of you is dark oh that's
good i mean you seem you're a very
friendly guy
i think you're you're very serious and
especially about these very complicated
issues and i think
that's one of the reasons why you have
made
this gigantic wave
uh in online discourse and people
discussing these
very tumultuous times we live in is
because you're a guy that
did extrapolate your guy did look at
that c-16 bill
and look at marxism and go do you know
where this is heading
and you were the guy that had the
courage to say murderous
and and people like what the [ __ ] is he
talking about that doesn't make any
sense
and you had to spell it out and explain
it and when you do
you realize why this is so significant
to you
yeah well the tribalism issue that you
were discussing earlier doesn't seem to
be
all that what would you say debatable
that if we degenerate into tribalism the
probability
of bloodshed becomes vastly enhanced
it's like well that always happens when
people
devolve into tribalism so when i'm
pointing to a particular kind of
tribalism
i guess the darkness is that you know
i'm very aware
of the terrible things that people not
only are likely to do to each other but
do do to each other all the time
i mean what it's about forty percent for
divorce rate right
you have to go you have to go through a
fairly fair bit of ugliness to get to
divorce
canadians are nicer than americans maybe
you guys have forty percent
maybe maybe i think we're gonna say yeah
i mean i think i i think actually it's
50 here
somewhere around the line but yeah yeah
you have to go through a lot that's yeah
that's really ugly too you know and
chris rock had a joke about that
he's like 50 of people uh get divorced
he goes
and he goes but that's just the people
who had the courage to leave he goes how
many
cowards just stay and suffer
and meanwhile he wound up getting
divorced a few years later and a
horrible divorce so yeah
true story yeah yeah yeah yeah
but it's a good point yeah i think um
we need um more people who are
actualized human beings more more people
who understand themselves more people
who have gone
through adversity both
in real life and personal in terms of
their understanding of their own growth
of their own potential
and their own understanding of how
they've managed their
their life their mind their their
actions
and the the more we have people that
have personal sovereignty
the better we'll be able to have these
these conversations
well that that be the hope you know one
of the things i've been
suggesting to people is that they pick
something difficult to do
i read this this funny little paragraph
by kierkegaard it was written about 1840
and
he was thinking about his role as a
student and writer and he was a student
and writer forever you know he never
really had a career apart from that
and he said that he wasn't one of these
people who was capable of
inventing something wonderful to make
life easier for everyone
like so many people were doing you know
during the industrial revolution he said
well
maybe i'm one of these people whose
benefit to society will be that i will
make things more difficult for everyone
because there will come a time
when what people want not they don't
want ease they want difficulty instead
and i think well that is what people
want that is what they want you think
well i want an easy happy life it's like
no actually
that isn't what you want i think what
people want is things that are difficult
that they can overcome
yeah right that's right they want an
optimal challenge well there's a whole
different thing when you overcome
something when you do something
difficult whether
it's i mean i've never written a book
but i assume when you write a book when
you're done writing that book there's a
great feeling of accomplishment because
it's very difficult to do
that feeling of accomplish for me it's
like when i put together a comedy
special
or when i you know just anything that's
difficult there's a
feeling like i did it yeah yeah well one
of the mysteries is why that feeling
exists you know it's a genuine it's not
a trivial thing that
it's to say i did something difficult
and that was worthwhile
basically what you're saying to yourself
is well there was a lot of suffering
attendant on that
along with the just general suffering of
life but it turned out that was worth it
that's what you want it's like you want
that sense that you're engaged in
something that's worth it
and i say well like i i try to i'm not a
like a casual optimist about these sorts
of things i mean
one of the things i do in 12 rules for
life is lay out the rationale
that drives people like the columbine
high school killers because i understand
that
rationale i've studied it for a long
time i know why they did what they did
and they have a powerful argument but
it's wrong
but you don't there's no sense in
showing how it's wrong before showing
that it's a powerful argument
like life is suffering there is lots of
malevolence it's no wonder that people
want to bring
being itself to a halt they want to take
revenge on it it's not surprising
it's the wrong way of going about it the
right way is it's
akin to the sorts of things that you
were just observing is you take on a
difficult task that
pushes you past where you are already
and you you succeed in it and you get
this sense that yes
that was worthwhile it's like that's
what you want you want to live in that
place where things are worthwhile
that's paradise on earth that's what
that is and it isn't
some happy little place where you know
someone's feeding you peeled grapes
that isn't what it is it's it's more
like it's
more like victory on the honorable
battlefield or something like that
yeah the the perception that people have
of ultimate success and ultimate
happiness is uh
it seems motivated by what they don't
have rather than an understanding of
what success and happiness really is
their idea is that one day i'm gonna go
and i'm gonna be
in my golden years and i'm just going to
be able to sit around and do nothing and
tell everybody to [ __ ] off
you won't be happy at all yeah i talked
to to one of the people that i was
working with
who had a like a vision for retirement i
said well what's your vision for
retirement
well i see myself in the beach you know
some tropical country drinking
margaritas and i thought
uh first that's not a plan that's a
travel poster it's like okay let's
let's walk through this all right so you
go down to this tropical country
and you go sit on the beach and you have
a margarita it's like okay well how many
margaritas
like 10. okay is it going to do that
we're going to do that for six months
you'll be dead yeah well you'll be this
like pathetic sunburned like
fat yeah unhappy hungover
yeah yeah it's like that's graduated so
how long can you have a margarita on a
beach
like maybe you can do that once every
six months for like 10 minutes something
like that
it's not a vision it's true but when you
are working and slaving away
you think about that beach with your
feet up and the waiter comes over would
you like another margarita mr peterson
yeah
yes i would absolutely like all right
right exactly but it's it's like this 16
year old fantasy of
paradise it's like well yes and it just
doesn't work out
so yeah and and the thing that the thing
is is
that the thing that sustains people
through life really is
the lifting of a worthwhile burden it's
something like that
and it's partly because we're social
animals right it's like we're evolved
to be useful to the people around us
because they're much more likely
to let us live if we're like that yeah
so
and and it's been very fun talking to
especially talking to young men about
this it's like
well and that's the other thing too is i
think the world the world is full of
darkness
let's say and we could say each of us
have a little bit of light and if
we release that light if we let it shine
properly
christ it's too cliche to go on with in
some sense but
the world is a lesser place if you do
not reveal
from within yourself what you have to
reveal and the fact that the world is a
lesser place actually turns out not to
be trivial
like if you aren't everything you could
be more people will die
more people will suffer more evil will
be unconstrained
more tyranny will reign more chaos will
remain
chaotic and dangerous all of that do you
mean this by this in the sense of like
the old proverb of the wings of a
butterfly fluttering become a hurricane
it's it's it's something similar to that
but it can even be more local it's like
your family is more messed up than it
could be if you were less messed up than
you are
right so if you just got your act
together like ten percent more
your family would be one percent better
right it's like well
do it and that would ripple off into the
people that they
interact yes yes and it ripples and it
ripples fast
yes that's the other thing that's so
cool is that like people think
well there's seven billion of us and
each of us is just this
separate dust moat like floating in the
cosmos and what the hell difference does
it make what you do anyways
it's like that is not how we're
connected it's like
you're the center of a network and you
know
well you know way more people than this
but let's say typically
you know without you're gonna know a
thousand people in your life well enough
to have an impact on them
okay and each of those thousand people
is gonna know a thousand people so
you're one step from a million and two
steps from a billion
and we are networked technically that
that's how human interactions work
and so when you do something that you
shouldn't do it's worse than you think
and when you do something that you
should do it's better than you think
and so you think well this is why i've
been telling people clean up your room
it's like well your room is actually
networked too it's not that easy to
clean up your room
to set it so you want your room to be
set up so that when you
walk in there it tells you to be better
than you generally are
it's organized it's got direction
everything's in its place
you try to do that in a chaotic
household you know i've watched people
do this because i had students do these
sorts of things as assignments i'd say
look
pick a small moral goal clean up your
room
and just write down what happens as a
consequence so maybe these are students
in a
chaotic household the whole place is a
bloody mess no one's taking any
responsibility for anything
and so they decide they're going to
start to clean up their room and then
the people in the household notice
well the first thing they do is get
pissed off it's like who do you think
you are
like you think you're better than us
like why do you think this is worthwhile
who made who died made you god all of
that so
just by trying to organize this little
part of their life they immediately run
into
the people whose actions they're casting
in a dim light by trying to improve
themselves to some degree they might
have to have like a
thorough war in their household to be
allowed to do something as simple as
keep the room orderly
they find out very rapidly that a that's
way more difficult than it sounds and b
that the consequences of it are far more
far-reaching than people think
so that's quite fun you know because
maybe part of it is is
that like everything around you is full
of potential
everything maybe more potential than you
could ever possibly utilize
and so maybe all you have is this little
rat hole of a room in some run-down
place in the world it's like
fix it up there's more there than you
think
see what happens if you fix it up and
you'll fix yourself up simultaneously
because you'll have to get disciplined
in order to fix up the room then you
have a fixed-up room and you'll be a
more fixed-up person it's like
you think that nothing will happen as a
consequence of that it's like all hell
will break loose as a consequence of
that
it's really worth trying it is worth
trying and it's it's a concept that
seems alien to people
but if you think about it it makes sense
well people don't take what they have
right in front of them seriously enough
it's like the wasting time thing they
don't do the arithmetic
you know and they also don't understand
they devalue what they have right in
front of them like another
another client i worked with was having
a hard time putting his kid to bed at
night
and so we we did the arithmetic it's
like well i'm fighting with my kid
for 45 minutes a night trying to get him
to go to bed okay so
let's analyze that all right so what
does that mean well it means that
both of you end the day upset that's not
so good because why would you want that
it means that you're spending 45 minutes
fighting when you could spend 20 minutes
doing something
positive like reading to him say means
that
you don't get to spend that time with
your wife so she's not very happy with
you plus you're annoyed because you
don't see her plus you blame it on the
kid because he's the proximal cause
it's like that's pretty damn ugly and
then and then let's do the arithmetic
it's like
seven days a week 45 minutes a day let's
call that five hours
20 hours a week 240 hours in a year
six you're spending a month and a half
of work weeks fighting with your
four-year-old son
you think you're going to like him you
don't like anyone you spend a month and
a half a year fighting with
it's a bad idea fix it it's important
get them to bed make it peaceful you do
it like these things that repeat every
single day that's a motif in this book
too
your life isn't margaritas on a beach in
in jamaica
that happens now and then those are
exceptions your life
is how your wife greets you at the door
when you come home
every day because that's like 10 minutes
a day
your life is how you treat each other
over the breakfast table
because that's an hour and a half or an
hour every single day
you get those mundane things right those
things you do every day you concentrate
on them and you make them pristine it's
like
you got 80 of your life put together
these little things that are right in
front of us
they're not little that's the first
thing they are not little and they're
hard to set right and if you set them
right it has a rippling effect and and
fast too way faster than people think i
want to talk about the rippling effect
because i know you got to get out of
here at one but i want to talk about the
rippling effect that you have had
on people and how how that makes you
feel i mean you were
relatively unknown just a year and a
half two years ago
and now you have become
i mean for lack of a better term you're
an online celebrity
and your your reach is fantastic now
this thing that you were talking about
about how your impact
can affect the people around you in a
not very
a not insignificant way a very
significant way what has that been like
for you i mean what is that adjustment
been like
oh i haven't adjusted to it how old are
you
55. so for 53 years
you're relatively anonymous outside of
universities yeah
yeah i had a little bit of you know a
little bit of exposure i did some work
with a
public television station in canada and
you know i had
my little flashes of public appearances
but compared to
oh yeah this is just crazy what you've
done on this show
mean millions yeah millions millions of
people have listened and watched
each sing each individual episode yeah
they're about two million views each and
and then that's nothing compared to
youtube youtube is nothing compared
to the audio yeah so the audio is like
five times that or something
yeah so so that's yeah it's completely
crazy no i haven't adjusted to it
it's like i don't know i mean have you
adjusted to your status
i'm numb yeah so but so what's it like
when you think about it
you wake up in the morning and you think
okay i'm i'm going to get a billion
downloads this year i don't think that i
i think i'm going to talk to jordan
peterson whatever i want to talk about
that's that's how i handle it
it's exactly the same thing for the last
15 months this is what i've done
got up in the morning i've looked at the
like
25 things i have to do in a mad rush
before seven o'clock at night
i think i'm going to go through them and
i'm going to concentrate on them
do the best job i can then at seven
o'clock tonight i'm gonna have a rest
i'm gonna take a look at what i have to
do tomorrow and i'm gonna do the same
thing
that's what i've been doing and then
when i stand back a little bit like when
it sort of dawns on me
you know then it's disconcerting like
it's surreal
i can't figure it out i can't understand
it but then i
but there's no sense dwelling on that
because
first of all i don't know how to
conceptualize i don't know why it's
happening exactly like i think what's
happened is that
two things one is that i said there was
something i wouldn't do
with regards to this legislation and i
meant it
i actually meant it i wasn't going to
use those words under legal compulsion
period no matter what and actually meant
that so there was that
but then i think the more relevant
thing is that i've been studying these
old stories these archetypal stories for
a very long period of time
and they have power they really have
power
and they manifest themselves everywhere
they manifest themselves in movies and
in books
i mean harry potter is a mythological
story and it made
roland richer than the queen of england
you know these stories have
power and i was fortunate enough to
study a
large number of people large number of
scholars who knew what that power was
carl jung in particular
and i could make it more accessible to
people
and so that's a big part of it but what
the overall significance of that is
well i just it just
leaves me speechless i mean this kathy
newman thing's a good example
and i mean so many things have happened
i've got involved i've been in a scandal
of some sort
a serious scandal of some sort probably
every three weeks
for a year and a half you know and there
are things that are just
well the james demour thing is a good
example of that like that's a big deal
you know that that explosion that
that emerged around him in the court
case that's coming out of it it's a big
deal and this thing with lindsey shepard
that was the worst scandal that ever hit
a canadian university and then there was
all the protests and
and then there was what happened with
with channel 4 in the uk
and it's like i don't know what to make
of it i don't
what what i'm trying to do is
have a good conversation when i come and
talk to somebody like you where we can
have a good conversation
try not to say anything stupid that's
really what i'm trying to do is to not
say anything stupid
that's hard or too stupid yeah yeah well
it's been high stakes poker
yeah you know for it's not quite so bad
now
because especially after what happened
with channel 4 and
some journalists like people have been
trying to take me out for quite a long
time and it's not
it isn't working so far
actually you actually believe what
you're saying and it actually makes
sense
well you know that's that's not a bad
start it's not a bad start but it's rare
in this world this is a
especially in these ideologically
charged times
this toxic tribalism that we keep
bringing up it's
well and i also decided like a long time
ago and and i
i think this runs through 12 rules for
life is
well i believe that people's decisions
tilt the world towards heaven or hell
i i think there's no more accurate way
of describing the consequences of each
of your decisions than that
you face potential that's what you face
that's what you face in the world is
potential it's not material reality
it's potential and every decision you
make
you're deciding whether you want to make
the world better or worse and
if you like the ultimate better is
heaven and the ultimate worse is hell
we know how to make the world into hell
we've done that multiple times
much of the 20th century was that it's
like i looked at all that and i thought
okay
i would rather that the world didn't
degenerate into hell
and i understand why people want it to
degenerate into hell they're angry
they're angry because they suffer they
suffer
unfairly and they suffer because people
hurt them
and so they think this is a bad game i'm
not going to help make it better
i'm angry i'm going to make it worse
even that's what the columbine kids did
you know that's what all the mass
shooters do they say to hell with this
i hate it they're going to make it
behind the game they just want to flip
the table over yeah worse than that they
they want to obliterate the game yes and
they want to do it with as much
malice as possible just to obtain
revenge and i understand that
but i decided a long time ago that i
would rather not play that game
i think it i think that it's possible
that we could make the world better
i really believe i believe that too so i
think well so i'm
i'm trying to tell people look there's
more to you than you think
there's more potential there's more than
enough potential to go around
there's definite suffering and
malevolence in the world we could fix it
you haven't got anything better to do
that's a very big point that there's
more potential to go around
more than people understand yeah we're
not going to run out of potential no
we're not and
this idea of the famine thinking is one
of the reasons why
people get upset at other people's
success they think somehow another this
other person's success
takes something away from them yeah yeah
well there's and it's it's
the other thing too is that i've
realized that people actually act like
what they confront in the world is
potential
it's so funny because whatever potential
is it's it's not materially measurable
but if you tell someone you're not
living up to your potential they go
yeah well i know that it's like what is
that potential that you're not living up
to
and then when you say well there's
potential in front of you you know that
you can walk out
on the street you go right or left or
straight ahead like
you're facing this thing that isn't
fully formed
and you get to decide how it's going to
form
and you can make it better and so my
question is like the world's a rough
place there's no doubt about it
it's a harsh place but my question is
what would happen if we stop making it
worse how good could it be
if we stop making it worse and i don't
know if there's an upper limit to that
like it might be maybe we could make it
really really really good
why not and we don't have anything
better to do than that it's like aim at
heaven
start at home aim at heaven
tell the truth let's see what the hell
happens you know like
it's it is the case clearly on the facts
of the matter
in 20 years there wouldn't have to be a
single person in the world that was
hungry
in 20 years we could get rid of the five
biggest diseases that
currently plague the planet we could
straighten things up
and god only knows what things could be
like that or we could let the whole
thing degenerate into hell
so when each of us is making that
decision with each decision that's the
other thing that i've understood
so take a choice you want hell or you
want heaven
if you pick hell just remember
you knew what you were doing when you
picked it but nobody picked so
yeah i just sort of let it slide yeah
but they do it because they blind
themselves
you know you know when you do it you say
ah well
you know i let that slide then you and
then you don't think about it it's like
you could think about it you could think
about it you could know
but you don't let yourself know is any
of this
all all the pressure and the scandal
every three weeks
is this uh this is it weigh on you
is it is it difficult uh how are you
feeling
like when when i'm feeling stressed it's
like
yeah it's like it's like simultaneously
the worst possible thing and the best
possible thing that could happen
well financially it's been a boom right
yes it's which is scenarios as oh well i
think yes
i mean the thing that i've i shouldn't
say this but i'm going to because it's
just so goddamn funny i can't help but
say it
i figured out how to monetize social
justice warriors
[Laughter]
that is what it is i know it's so funny
i just can't believe it
the other way it just every time i think
that well it's just one of the surreal
circumstances that characterize my life
it's like i'm driving the social justice
activists in
canada mad because if they let me speak
then i get to speak and then more people
support me on patreon
it's like that's annoying it's like
goddamn capitalistic make more money off
this ideological warfare it's like okay
fine
let's go protest so they go protest me
and then that goes up on youtube and
then my patron
account goes way up so it's like they
don't know what to do
and so one of the things they keep
accusing me of yeah they keep accusing
me of uh
like hauling in the loot and i think
well look here's the situation guys
i give away everything i do online
for free it's free
and people are giving me money they're
just sending it to me i'm not twisting
there i'm not even asking them for it
well
i guess that's not exactly right because
i set up the patreon account but that's
more complicated than it looks that a
lot of that was curiosity
and i thought well i could increase the
production quality of my online videos
was also the potential of you being
removed from the universe well they're
yes
well that and that was really potential
oh yeah oh and yeah
people wanted that yeah they haven't
stopped wanting that yes
in in october when the lindsay shepherd
scandal broke and it
looked so bad for the left-wing
ideologues like 200
university of toronto a community member
signed a petition to get me fired again
and i was kind of upset about that and
this is what my life has been like
so my son came over that day and i said
jesus julian you know what like 200
people at the faculty mem
at in at the university of toronto
petitioned the faculty association
and then they sent in a petition to the
administration to get me fired it was
the faculty association that's
my union they didn't even contact me and
julian said uh
don't worry about it dad it was only 200
people and i thought
that's what my life is like it's like a
day where
200 people sign a petition to get me
fired as a professor
my son can come in and say well that's
not so bad it's like it's only two
hundred people that's how like where the
scale is
yeah that's right it's so it it's so
surreal
because you could say that online
and look what's happening and then the
support would be overwhelming from
who knows how many people well the
administration times of that
yeah absolutely well in the
administration at the university of
toronto like
that they didn't they didn't take it
seriously at all the call to have me
removed it didn't cause
any didn't even cause a ripple now who
are these 200 people what was their
motivation
oh well they're hard to say what their
motivation is
very happy about they read the
transcript or listen to those recordings
yeah how could they possibly be against
you based on that oh because they think
that the people who
who who conducted the inquisition were
right
well that's madness oh yes but
look look i mean i mean this formerly
like 20 members of
pimlots and rambuchana's faculty that
was communications at wilford laurier
wrote a letter supporting them
so that's why it's not an isolated
incident it's like no no they thought
that what they were doing was right
it's mass hysteria yeah well there is an
element of that that's for sure
and there's certainly again i hate to
bring this term up again but this toxic
tribalism thing it's like they're
they're supporting their own
and they understand that their own
ideologies have been completely
connected
to the same type of group think that's
going against
lindsay shepard in that meeting oh yeah
when they tried to paint her as a
radical right winger and
she certainly isn't of course not
neither are you i mean the whole thing
is ridiculous
you're not alt-right you're not a
neo-nazi you're not i've read a lot of
crazy things about you
and knowing you personally seeing this
stuff i'm like this is
this is a fascinating time that's for
sure that's for sure yeah and it's been
well it's been crazily well i'm
what would i say crazily stressful it's
it's the best way to describe it is
surreal
yeah like i'm it's like i stepped
outside myself i
can't i can't put this in a box
i don't know what to make of it i don't
know what to make of the channel 4
interview
you know it's like what the hell really
it's it's
it's crazy well it's it's
this these conversations are so limited
by what you were saying before that
they're trying to get this five-minute
sound bite in and that's what television
has become
yeah it's a dying medium yeah it doesn't
make any sense it doesn't make any sense
to sandwich these commercials in every
15 minutes or whatever they do
none of it makes any sense it's an
archaic way of communicating ideas
yeah well then i think that is part of
it too is that like i happen to catch
a technological wave well like you did
you know yeah i mean
they're they're television offers
nothing
over youtube nothing
yeah well exactly yeah and there's no
space requirements on youtube
so you don't have to do this twist the
complex event into a short sound bite
and entertain everyone
right and it turns out too that there's
this huge audience online for
actual content like just genuine
conversation
because like one of the things that's
happened between you and i when i've
come down here is
we've actually had a conversation right
we're trying to figure things out
you know we've got our viewpoints and
everything but we're basically and
i outline this and there's a chapter in
12 rules for life called
uh assume that the person you're talking
to might know something you don't
which is like the formula for good
conversations like
there's a bunch of things i don't
understand about the world i mean
that's a big book things i don't
understand about the world right that's
a very thick book
and i can come in here and talk to you
about what's going on and hopefully we
both emerge with better understanding
we're not the same people that we were
when we walked
in and that's a good thing and then we
have those conversations online and
people can participate in that
and i'm trying to do that in my lectures
too like when i when i did this
biblical series because that was another
thing that was so strange joe was like
imagine i walked into a like a venture
capitalist uh
um organization i said look i want you
guys to bankroll me
i'm gonna do 15 lectures on the old
testament and i'm going to try to
attract young men
i'm going to rent a theater like they
just laughed me out of there see can you
imagine
anything less saleable than that
so but i did that i went ahead with it i
rented the theater and then i walked
through these stories and i was learning
a lot because
like i knew this first stories in
genesis up to the flood i knew them
pretty well i knew kind of understood
what they meant
but then all the stories from abraham
onward that i had read them but
i hadn't done a detailed in-depth
analysis and so i was learning a
tremendous amount walking through those
stories
and they had a big like they've had a
big impact man
and so i'm going to do exodus soon
because i want to do that but
it's just another example of how surreal
things have become
but also the use the utility of a good
conversation because like when i'm up on
on on the podium say lecturing i'm not
exactly lecturing
i'm trying to figure something out and
sharing that process with the audience
which is so different than what is going
on in universities that is freaking
everybody out
it's what's going on is this
indoctrination into this
group thing yeah it's like here's what's
right memorize it right
it's like my lectures are more like well
i don't know what's right like here's
some things i know and
they seem to be working and here's how i
use those tools to dig at this story and
here's what it might mean and
this is what i got from it and here's
some universal truths about human beings
that seem to be and then i try to
explore that it's like well should we
believe this should we
like when abraham in the abrahamic story
for example i mean abraham's an old guy
and he's basically lived in his mom's
basement that's that's really the
beginning of the story
he gets a call to adventure you know god
says well get get away from your family
and your kin get out there in the world
it's the call to adventure think okay
fine that's a heroic motif
but then abraham goes out and the first
thing he encounters is like tyranny and
starvation and then a bunch of guys who
want to steal his wife
so it's it's been entertaining to take
those stories apart and to see why
they're foundational
because they are foundational and
they're not
mere ignorance
that what whatever they are ignorant
superstition
is not the right category how has this
changed your classrooms
well i haven't gone back teaching since
all of this hit
because when did you stop teaching well
oh no i guess that's not true that's not
true i taught from january
to may of of 2016. well
the first way it changed it was that i
was like so so
shell-shocked when i went to to teach
last january that and i was really sick
like i've been really sick this year
i had like last january jesus it was
just dismal i wouldn't worship
wish that on my worst enemy i had three
weeks where i didn't sleep a wink
try that that's really entertaining one
long day of misery that's three weeks
long what kind of a an illness
it looks like an autoimmune disorder do
you think this is because of stress
no i don't you don't think it's
connected at all well yeah i think it
probably made it worse but no
it's something that i've battled with
for a long time and it's something that
really
both my wife and i have autoimmune
illness and my daughter got
what i mean don't know exactly what it
is
i don't know what it is in my daughter
it manifests yes
that's what's fixed what what fixed it
oh all i eat is meat and greens
that's it no juice no no vegetables no
carbohydrates
meat greens that's it and that fixed it
that seems to have fixed it yeah that
fixes so many people i can tell
if you've listened to the podcast i've
done yeah yeah yeah yeah well i've been
following them because my daughter has a
blog too called don't eat that and
my daughter had a hair terrible
autoimmune disorder it was awful i
detailed that out in chapter 12.
she had 38 affected joints and she had
her hip and her ankle replaced when she
was 16.
jesus so she walked around on two broken
legs for a year
in excruciating pain she was on
extremely high doses of opiates
and so she was addicted to opiates which
she like she just
once she had her surgery she just went
off them cold turkey and like suffered
through the withdrawal for two months
and
compared to what she had been through
that was nothing like what she went
through man you
it was dreadful and that was just the
surface of it like that was only the
beginning of her illness she had all
sorts of other things that were worse
than that
and so and we figured she was probably
going to die by the time she was 30
because my cousin's
daughter had a similar autoimmune
problem and she died when she was 30.
so it was bloody dreadful but she
figured out at one point that it was
associated with diet and then she went
on a radically restrictive diet
and she christ she she was on
antidepressants
she's not she had to take ritalin to
stay awake she could only stay awake
about six hours a day and she had to
take high doses of ritalin to stay awake
she what is this autoimmune disease well
she had
her diagnosis was rheumatoid arthritis
right but
she didn't have the blood markers for it
but she had all the other symptoms
anyway she she figured out this
restrictive diet she only ate chicken
and broccoli for about two months
and almost all her symptoms went away
and she's pretty much symptom free now
and which is it's a complete miracle
and she convinced me to try this diet
about a year and a half ago
and so i lost seven pounds a month for
seven months that was the first thing
which was just bloody amazing yeah it
was unbelievable it was unbelie i
couldn't believe it you know well you
was your diet rich in refined
carbohydrates before that
rich enough yeah rich enough you know
um pastas and bread yeah bread bread
bread in particular i eat a lot of bread
um so the first thing that happened was
i quit snoring that happened immediately
took took one week and i was snoring
quite badly that so that disappeared in
a week
and that was amazing i thought oh that's
interesting and then i had gastric
reflux disorder that went away
and then i lost seven pounds the first
month i thought oh that's a lot
seven pounds i had psoriasis that went
away i had floaters
in my right eye which is also not immune
problem that went away
um i have had gum disease for 30 years
that went away that went away that's
amazing i'm 55 like my gum disease went
away
it's ridiculous so i figured all that
out
so my life in the last year was so so
strange
because i'd get up in the morning and
i'd think
god all these bloody scandalous things
are happening around me and
i have to deal with that and then i
think i need a break but i can't eat
anything
i can't eat anything because if i ate
the wrong thing it would like knock me
out for a month
so i was trying to figure out what the
hell was wrong with my diet and i was
feeling wretched and so it was like
if i it was like wolves at the back door
and crocodiles at the front door
something like that
so but but whatever
like i'm down to the same weight i was
when i was 25.
wow yeah no kidding and i've got lots of
energy i wake up in the morning
and i wake up that's never happened to
me my whole life i've always had to have
a shower like took me an hour to wake up
my whole life
that's gone i'm not hungry um i don't
have hypoglycemia
i have lots of energy um
i can't eat anything but so i can't go
out for dinner but you can't eat
nonsense you can eat i mean i'm on the
same dime i eat meat and greens
i don't have a disorder like you did
in the same regard but i take a day
where i have a cheat day you know i
don't even do it every week well i'll
have a cheeseburger or something like
that yeah
but for the most part that's the diet
that i follow as well yep
well for some people it seems like like
uh well
for a massive amount of people well i
think for far more people than we know i
think people are
carbohydrate poisoning themselves like
they can't believe yes
and along with all the other things that
go along with it insulin
yeah you know the high blood sugar is
not good cholesterol
in this this idea that uh cholesterol
and saturated fat are the problems that
people
are experiencing it's not true no the
real problem is sugar
and cholesterol has been demonized you
know i'm sure you read the article from
the new york times about the sugar
industry
paid off scientists to lie about the
results yep
yep well i know too that two food
scientists in the uk
resigned about three years ago they were
they were part and parcel of the
organization that had produced the food
pyramid they said it was the worst
public health disaster the last 40 years
they pretty much got it backwards yeah
and you look around you know you drive
through the u.s
it's really obvious in the u.s people
are overweight like mad
like yeah like crazy it's crazy
ridiculous go to
disneyland yeah exactly it's insane it
is but you know and the reason is
as far as i can tell the reason is is
that they're
they're poisoning themselves with
carbohydrates that's what it looks like
and the thought process is so out of
whack i i
um retweeted an article today from nina
thai schultz uh she
she tweeted it about um this
trend of eating only egg whites and how
terrible it is for you so it's a health
disaster
and this idea that cholesterol from the
egg yolk is bad for you it's one of the
most important things you can eat
it's and then weight watchers is
adjusted yeah see it goes
weight watchers diet program now adjust
their uh
pro their uh protocol and they say that
eat all the eggs you want it is now a
zero point food
which is [ __ ] incredible yeah yeah
yeah so and the way i don't get hungry
is i eat a lot of oil like a lot of
olive oil
yes so and that that keeps fats so
you're basically
burning fat you're on like a ketogenic
diet yeah yeah
so and it seems to be well and that was
complex that would have been complicated
enough to keep me occupied for the last
two years especially sorting it out with
my daughter because she
well that was quite the bloody nightmare
i can tell you it was really something
but i can't believe she figured it out
it's amazing it is amazing and like
she's really
she's in pretty damn good shape she just
had a baby like five months ago so that
was that's amazing
too yeah we're we're stunned man we're
stunned because like it was
it was rough well she sounds like an
incredibly she is
quite the tough cookie that girl sounds
like it yeah
many people are experiencing the same
revelation that their diet is killing
look
i was tired all the time i would hit a
net i mean i was always very very active
so i stayed lean
because of my physical activity but by
the end of the day
i need a nap i would always take a nap
before i'd go to jiu jitsu i was like i
have to take a nap or i can't train
yeah and it's because of carbohydrates
yeah i had i'd nap about two hours a day
yeah and now i don't nap at all me too
same thing that's not exactly true when
i've been zooming around i take like two
minute naps when i'm in the airport or
whatever
well that's also you're probably not
getting enough sleep yeah right exactly
big difference
exactly so yeah it's been it's been
remarkable so
so why did you stop teaching
oh well i took a sabbatical because of
all this
yeah well i told i told my department
chair i said look i i had a sabbatical
coming up next year i said look you know
i there's too much going on it'll be
better if i take the sabbatical this
year then i can concentrate on my
teaching next year so you take the
entire year off
yeah so you're about eight months in is
that yeah correct yeah well then i
always teach from i put all my courses
from january to
march i teach all them in the same
semester and that enabled me to
concentrate on my research
and for the rest of the time and so
technically i'll be going back teaching
in january of 2019.
technically technically you're not
convinced well
well i can't think a year ahead at the
moment
right i don't know what the hell's going
like i'm not going to go back and teach
the same way
right because see at some point
the technological transformation means
you have to approach things differently
and so now if i do a lecture online
whatever the lecture happens to be
i can get 150 000 people to watch it
that's minimum
so the first question would be well why
would i teach 300 people when i could
teach 150
000. that's just stupid who would do
that those same 300 people
also have access to the hundreds well
exactly that's right that's exactly it
and the next thing is well i taped my
maps of meeting class and my personality
class for three years running
it's like it's there well i could do it
again but
why right it's taped right i would
rather
lecture about new things so that's what
i did this year i did this biblical
series which i hadn't done before
but now if i'm going to lecture again
i'm going to lecture about
different things because because the
technology has transformed the landscape
we're not in
1990 anymore not even a little bit right
so and this is something i brought up to
brett weinstein and i'm hoping he falls
along the same line same bet weinstein
not steen i make that mistake often
sorry brett
but same thing brilliant guy restricted
by his university big scandal leaves
and i'm hoping he follows the same path
because he has so much to offer
and he has so much to offer for anybody
who can get online well and
one of the things that's really fun
about youtube
that and having my lectures on youtube
is that the only reason people watch
them is one reason
is because they want to learn that's it
right and so
it's you might think well where is the
university
well the university is where people want
to learn right it's like okay
well youtube is the university because
there's
hundreds of thousands of people on
youtube maybe millions
who just want to learn it's like fine
i'm an educator i'll talk to people who
want to learn because
if you're an educator that's what you do
is that most effectively done in the
universities
not self-evidently and so now i'm trying
to figure this out you know like
i like my job at the university and u of
t has treated me well apart from this
scandal thing but they were kind of
taken aback by they didn't know what to
do about that you know it was a new law
and when i made the video criticizing
bill c-16 i said i think that
making this video is probably illegal in
and of itself
was there controversial moments in your
career before that
no wow no i mean it surprised me because
i've always
i would say that the content of my
lectures has
been atypical but it's been atypical in
a good way like the student response to
my lectures has always been
well extremely good extremely good i'm
always surprised that i was
able to teach what i'm teaching because
i always thought that it was
like insanely revolutionary but it was
revolutionary in a really
like in a scholarly way you know like
i'm a careful scientist i'm a careful
thinker i think things all the way
through to the bottom
and i'm really self-critical like when i
wrote maps of meaning which was my first
book
i suspect i rewrote every sentence at
least
15 times it's probably more than that
and i really literally mean rewrite it
so i
take the sentence out of the paragraph
put it in another document
write like 10 variants of the sentence
and then pick the one that was best
and i did that like it took me 15 years
to write i did that over and over and
over and so what i was
i'd write a sentence and then i'd think
okay have i got all the words right
every single word is that the proper
words the proper phrase is the proper
sentence
do i believe that this sentence is true
then i'd think like
of 10 ways i could attack it and see if
i could break it apart and
find out what it was wrong and i only
kept the ones that i couldn't destroy
and like i was going out full force to
destroy them because
i wanted to come up with a you know come
on i wanted to produce a book
that i could not break no matter what i
did
and so i spent 15 years on that and then
that was the basis well it's the basis
for 12 rules for life it's been the
basis for all the lectures i've done and
so forth and
like i can't see where it's wrong and
mostly what i was trying to do was to
see where it was wrong and i can't get
underneath it i can't break it
that's what's so fascinating to me about
all this stuff and
not to not to
overly exaggerate the significance of
this but just to be completely honest
about it
you're the right guy for the job and it
sort of found you
it's real weird because there's not a
lot of people that are that
meticulous about their thoughts and
about their work and about their writing
and about their
criticizing their own ideas to the point
where they break them down and try to
break them try
them apart i had a big problem so when i
when i started to write maps of meaning
i thought okay
what's the situation this is the cold
war we've divided into two armed tribal
camps
and we've decided that settling the
difference between us is worth
risking being itself we could
we could drive everything into
extinction we're willing to take that
chance
it's like what the hell is going on so i
wanted to know two things
what was truly driving the tribalism of
the cold war
including its including the generation
of that
vast nuclear arsenal because that just
seemed to me to be
insanity taken to the final
pinnacle so i wanted to know that and i
wanted to know okay
having figured out why that's happening
what could be done about it so it would
stop and at the same time i was also
studying
what had happened in auschwitz and with
the nazis and all of that
and so it was a very serious problem and
i actually wanted to have the answer i
actually wanted the answer
i didn't want to write an interesting
book about it it wasn't even that i
wanted to write a book exactly
it was just that writing a book was the
best way to figure out the problem
because it's
it's writing a book is so rigorous you
know because you think but you can only
remember
so much you have to write it down
because then you can remember way more
you can write and then the next day you
can go back and think okay
i'm going to take that goddamn argument
apart i'm going to see if there's
anything about it that's weak
and so and i think i did figure it out i
think i did figure it out so
and then when i when i well and then i
started
lecturing about it and the lectures were
always unbelievably well
regarded like people the kids in the
classes would always write
for the evaluations at the end of the
year eighty percent of them would say
and this happened for 20 years to say
this class changed everything about the
way i look at the world
it's like yeah that's what happened to
me too and i wrote that book it's like
i didn't think the same way at all when
i was done i started to understand what
these ancient stories meant it was like
shocking never recovered from it
wow listen you're out of time
thank you always 12 rules for life
an antidote to chaos jordan peterson i
made a
i made a discount for your viewers again
for the future authoring program
okay so what do they have to do rogan
just use rogan and how do they
get to the website selfauthoring.com
okay yeah
yeah and i'll send you a link for that
thanks a lot and also thanks for
everything eh
really you were the portal into this
weird world that i'm in
and people say that all the time they
come up and say look i heard about you
on joe rogan it's like
and like thousands of people have told
me that so well it's been it's your
fault
it's been an honor i appreciate it sir
thank you you bet